She got to tell these fucking people,
Jesus Christ.
There's a lot of people that don't even
know this podcast is happening right
now.
This is a disaster.
I will right now tweet it as I'm
talking.
That's how slick I am.
Not very slick at all.
Just bear with me.
This is gonna.
Be clunky.
They're going to be like,
I thought this was a good podcast.
Here we go.
Bitches.
Let's see.
Here we go.
Retweet it.
Please do.
Let me know.
That's called being lazy too.
I'll let y'all do all the work that can
hashtagging and then I'll just retweet
it.
Um,
I do a lot of retweet until it's too
much work.
When people ask you to just tweet
things,
hey,
tweet this for me,
bitch.
You're not even treating yourself like
Brian Callan.
That motherfucker will tell you,
hey,
tweet that.
I'm here.
Tweet that I'm here.
And then you go to his twitter page.
You,
I had to do this wrestling class.
And there was a guy that navigator.
I had to see this episode of the Joe
Rogan experience podcast is brought to
you by squarespace.com.
Squarespace.com
is a website that allows you to build
websites very easily.
It's a.
it's set up so that like a dummy like
you or I could easily make.
Notice how I said you were.
I thought I was going to say me.
I'm tricky.
It's A.
Essentially it's set up so that a simple
person like myself could easily make a
website and you can do it really
quickly.
Choose from over 20 bad ass designs.
You can if you need help,
they have 24 slash seven super fast
email support.
You also can start it and try it without
paying for it.
You don't even have to enter your credit
card information just to have so much
confidence that it's a cool website for
creating websites that they allow you to
play with it first and then if you
decide like,
wow,
this,
this website that I made super easy,
it's fucking bad ass.
You can easily register it and you can
easily start an online store.
So it's.
It's a pretty sweet account and if you
use the codename Rogan,
oh no,
don't even use the code named Joe and
the number eight.
There's 20 of these codes,
a squarespace.com,
squarespace.com,
and use the offer code Joe and then the
number eight,
so if you decided to purchase a,
you get a 10 percent off and the number
eight is because it's the month of
August,
so it's all one word.
They're really tricky like that.
They want to know like exactly what
month people tuned in and got a
squarespace.com
account,
but it's a bad ass website.
You'll enjoy it.
Go check it out.
We're also brought to you by
audible.com.
If you go to audible.com
forward slash Joe,
you can get one free audio book and 33
days of honorable service audible,
which also has opie and Anthony,
which is why I became deeply acquainted
with my little buddy Jimmy Norton and
his book.
Best of Jim Norton and volume two.
Oh,
that's not a book I got to pile audio.
It's audio.
Put that together.
I guess fans did or something.
I Dunno.
Yeah.
Well opie and Anthony,
you know,
all the shows are on audible,
so I like that.
That's the coolest thing ever said.
Like if you missed yesterday's show,
you just go online and download the show
and I think they touched,
took all the best parts of a Jimmy on
opie and anthony.
This is volume two.
So there's a few of them and uh,
it says an hour and 10 minutes.
And you said one of your books is
available,
right?
Yeah.
Happy ending.
And I did the voice read for an audio
book.
I didn't do it for,
I hate your guts.
How come you didn't do no time?
No.
I wish I had,
but because when I did the happy endings
one,
it was such an annoying process to go
through because they like,
she's like say it like this and say it
like that.
And I listened to her but I'm like,
I'm a comic.
I know how to talk.
I should have just done when she's
telling you how to do it,
how to read it.
So it's clear like,
and they do that with everybody,
but it's like I should have overrode or
on a fuel it.
No,
I know how to do that.
Yeah,
you can have that kind of impact.
You're not going to put out a bad
product.
I know you when you're trying to do the
best thing that you can do it.
You can't do that.
When people were trying to change your
annunciations or micromanage.
Yeah.
That becomes a problem.
I,
I had a book deal and I gave back the
money because of that video.
Yeah.
I didn't want to deal with it.
They were,
they were trying to get me to write it
like a stand up and stand up for him and
we kind of had such a gap between what
they wanted and what I wanted to do was
so wide that I was like,
I don't think it's fair because I can't.
I can't make your book what dummies they
are.
Well,
they have an idea of what they think
could sell.
They actually wanted me to try to do my
standup in book form and I was like,
there's no way I would do that.
And they go,
but George Carlin did it and Jerry
Seinfeld did it.
I'm like,
that's great,
and those guys are great comics.
I said,
I don't care.
I don't.
I'm not gonna.
Do that.
I'm never going to do that.
I'm never going to put my fucking stand
stand,
stand up,
stand up for a reason.
It's supposed to be that way and it's
cheating in a way.
It's just cheating.
Instead of coming up with a new book.
You just taking.
That's lazy thinking by publishers are
copy editors.
Well it was just gross.
I think they just trying to make money
and it led me think that they were just
trying to make the most money possible.
They weren't really worried about it
being good.
Otherwise you would never propose that.
So it was just,
we just had a different idea of what to
do.
So I understand where you're coming
from,
but you know,
hey,
they're in the business of making money.
You know,
they're not in the business of being Jim
Norton.
Yeah.
You know,
that's the problem.
No one to fucking tell you mean.
Think about all the crazy shit you've
ever said and how many people could,
would suggest that that would be a good
thing to talk about.
Meanwhile,
it's made you who you who you are.
They're idiots.
So Joey and his book is I usually $23
and ninety three cents,
but if you sign up right now,
you get this book
for free.
Good googly Mowgli.
Go check it out.
Go to audible.com
and a audible.com/joe.
And.
Or did they change that now?
Didn't they change that?
This is the hall ridiculous that it has
to be with squarespace.
Squarespace changed.
I think automotive is still basically
the same thing.
Yeah,
they all should be the same thing.
But uh,
the point
Kim,
that you,
you'd go to a lot of massage parlors.
Have you heard of Roadmaps Dotcom yet?
No.
It's going to be your new favorite
website.
You can be addicted to it.
It's pretty much yelp for massage
parlor.
Go there and realize that Brian got
jerked up by the Gal right before you.
Oh yeah.
But it has like reviews and like if you
want a hand job and went full sex,
you want whatever.
And it tells you all the places around
here,
man.
Yeah,
it's great.
Great.
Nice views.
Yeah,
be great if that was all legal and we
can just be like gentlemen and discuss
this.
Oh that would be wonderful.
She's an Asian but she has bad breath,
but she will eat your ass for an extra
30,
slightly bruised.
But meanwhile we're like,
why would you do that?
What do you want a job?
Jeremy's books.
Awesome.
The one that's on tape you can
get@audible.com
for free.
Go audible.com
forward slash Joe.
You get one free audio book and 33 days
of audible service.
Did I ever give you any of the audit
stuff that ever get you?
Any of the Alpha brain or any of that
shit?
No,
I don't think so.
To get you something like what you did
there.
How dare you?
Oh,
what was that Wayne's room I just
started bringing,
not a dust.
Not Off.
I haven't even tried that years.
Not
any out of nowhere.
Uh,
if you haven't been to [inaudible] dot
com.
So I'll last sponsor.
We sell what we call things.
It's what we call it,
human performance website.
Everything we sell on it is in some way
going to benefit you physically or
mentally or your,
your,
your cardio or your,
your mental health.
There's a a bunch of different strength
and conditioning exercise,
equipment pieces that we sell.
We sell kettle bells and battle ropes
and weight vests and steel maces and
club bells.
All Shit that really promotes functional
strength,
strength that you could apply to
athletics,
whether it's martial arts or a sport or
something along those lines.
And then the supplements we,
we,
we sell is essentially the best shit
that we can find in every category.
What's the,
where's the best protein powder that's
made out of hemp?
What's,
where's the best a spirulina.
Where's the Best Melatonin?
We just sell the best shit we can get
and we try to sell it at a reasonable
rate and we sell it through the
Internet.
So the whole thing is done easily and
smoothly.
We don't have to deal with any third
party and if you're interested in these
supplements,
which are the most controversial thing
that we sell,
you know people like what caused it
helps your endurance,
what it makes you brainwork what it's a
lot of people don't want to believe
things.
So we have a science thing set up at
[inaudible] dot com,
explains the science behind all this and
then on top of that there's also a 30
pill,
90 day money back guarantee,
so you don't even have to return the
product.
You say,
hey,
this stuff didn't do shit for me and you
get your money back.
No one's trying to rip you off.
All we're trying to do is just sell you
shit that I use shit.
That arbor used shit that my friends
use.
Alpha brain is what's called a
nootropic.
Nootropics are his nutrients that are
have been shown in certain studies to
enhance certain aspects of cognitive
function.
Whether it's being able to problem solve
or memory or there's other supplements
like new mood,
which is a five htp supplement,
which is great for your serotonin
development and also has l trip to fan
which converts to five htp.
I'm talking too much.
Any of these questions you need answered
on any of this stuff?
You can go to [inaudible] dot com.
It's o,
n n I t if use a codename Brogan,
you'll save 10 percent off any and all
supplements.
My Pal Jimmy Norton is here.
Cue The music.
Brian,
let's get frisky first year experience.
That's the most magical intro we've ever
given.
You still?
I feel like there's some energy in the
air and I said that it's going on my
brother.
Good to see you.
I'm okay.
I'm drinking this coffee and it's very
good with the butter in it,
but I know that I'm going to be any of
that stuff like lactose just fucks me up
so I know him a lot.
Yeah,
I'm done.
I'll be interested to see if it has the
same effect on you because it's grass
fed butter.
Wonder if that has the same effect.
You know what I find,
I find that I could be lactose
intolerant,
but when I drink raw milk,
I don't have any problem which the grass
fed butter effect.
Well the idea is,
and obviously I'm no doctor so don't
listen to me,
but the idea is that butter from grass
fed cows is butter from healthier cows
and cows are not designed to eat corn
and when they eat corn it's one of the
reasons why they get so fucking fat,
right?
It's just not a part of their normal
diet,
their normal diet.
It's just grass.
And when you have grass fed beef it's a
much leaner beef tastes different and
the idea is the butters different too
and the butter is actually healthy for
you as opposed to the butter that you're
getting.
That's from corn fed cows.
The other thing is the homogenization
and pasteurization of milk changes so
much about how your body absorbs it,
like the enzymes in it and everything
you ever had.
Like raw milk.
I don't know.
I don't love milk.
I drink it out of necessity and other
shit.
But like,
I can never be the professional just
walking around lugging milk at how bad
his breath must be.
Drink fucking milk.
That was supposed to be like the sign
that you're a serious man.
Did you ever see the movie,
the Hustler a give me with Paul Newman?
Yes.
Yeah,
sure.
Do you remember the Jackie gleason's
backer was George C dot Scott and George
C dot Scott.
Played Burt and Bert Gordon and he drank
a glass of milk everywhere.
Everybody else,
everybody's getting fucked up left and
right.
They're all drinking whiskey and they're
all fucking bar just over there drinking
a glass of milk.
He's serious as serious gambler.
Oh Wow.
No,
I never saw that.
I remember the movie.
I don't remember that part of it.
I guess it was like,
I want to say 63.
Yeah.
I want to say it was 1963.
That's a great fucking movie.
The Guy,
the guy fat changed his name because of
that.
Minnesota statues.
Gleason.
What was the real,
the original fashion wander.
Own Rudolph Rudolph wander own.
I think that's his real name.
Yeah,
I think it's Rudolph wander own.
Um,
he,
uh,
he was not even the best pool player of
his era,
not even close Moscone was,
and they used to have these,
these matches and Moscow and he hated
the fact that people only knew him
because he played Minnesota fats because
Minnesota fats stole the name off the
movie.
It was a brilliant move.
He said that was based on me.
He was a really eccentric character.
Minnesota fats.
It wasn't,
he was a bad pool player.
He was a really good pool player,
but he was a hustler.
Right.
And he,
he had like 100 cats.
He was one of those guys,
he used to go to Kentucky Fried Chicken
and he picked up like two buckets of
chicken and he would just tossed them in
his yard and like 100 cats would come in
and tear the chicken apart.
Like that's what he did every day.
That was his thing.
Yeah.
And like a gang of stray animals that he
fed.
So he was an interesting guy,
but he wasn't.
The character wasn't based on on him,
the character in most likely it was just
a base and a bunch of different pool
players.
What's fiction added to it?
My priest years ago when I was in North
Brunswick,
his name is father miserables.
He's dead now,
but his brother was a very famous steve
miserable,
right?
Yeah.
That was showing off for his cousin
though.
I just don't remember what it was.
Yeah,
he was the guy that did those
commercials on Miller lite,
I think,
right?
Yeah.
Every now and then a guy like sneaks
through and becomes famous through a
sport where no one else is famous.
Like in pool.
Everybody says,
Jeanette Lee,
do you and do you know who he is?
Now if you tell someone that you play
pool,
people go,
do you know who genetically is?
She's this really beautiful woman who
was also.
She was a pool champion.
She doesn't play,
I don't think as much anymore,
but she was on espn a lot.
She might be back into it,
I don't know,
but she's beautiful and she plays really
pool and she wears all black and her
nickname is the black widow and she's
Korean so she's got this dark black hair
and she's pretty and so people go nuts
for.
So she's like the Lance Armstrong and I
don't mean this about performance
enhancement.
I mean by Lance Armstrong cancer,
either one with Lance Armstrong is the
only bike guy I've ever heard of.
Like I guess Greg Lamont,
he,
he was one that I had heard of like way
back in the past.
But as far as like being able to name
professional cycles,
I can after Lance Armstrong and no one
cares about any of them.
If you talk about like professional pool
players almost everybody goes,
oh,
what about the black widow?
Like that woman.
I seen her but I don't know.
I bet you have.
She's in,
she's in commercials too.
I'm sure she just,
she does a lot like.
But she's been the most successful at
utilizing her image and like,
and becoming famous and a sport where
almost no one's famous like it's for
Popeyes is tough time.
There's no this,
it's very hard to make a living.
It's very hard to become famous and
there's a hard to express the
personality there or something that
differentiates you and makes you likable
that Oh,
it is bigger than the sport.
Like maybe she has that.
Maybe there's some hot dude.
She's hot and she plays pool.
That's what it is,
you know.
And she's very savvy as far as marketing
rather wide backed girl,
big girl with her.
Ellen,
that celebrity poker thing.
I didn't get actually get to play with
her.
Um,
I've,
I've played in a tournament and she was
the commentator,
which was kind of crazy.
She's commentating on me playing pool,
you know,
world class professional.
But luckily I was playing against people
that didn't have any idea what they were
doing.
I liked pool and hated.
I don't find it relaxing at all to me
because I stink at it and I suck at long
green shots.
Like,
uh,
I'm just,
I'm fairly hideous at Paul and I never
found it enjoyable because I just can't
get the hang of it.
Tools,
one of those things.
It gets enjoyable when you get really
good.
Yeah.
As you get really good,
then it becomes like really satisfying
if you can get into a groove and run out
racks and you get in good position.
So satisfying that cocky walk around the
table and I've never taken.
I just fucking shamefully go from point
a to point B and hope I don't scratch
like a cunt.
The worst is playing in a bar.
Oh,
a bunch of people crowded around a table
and drinking and bumping into shit.
And it's what a ridiculous idea of
precision game in a bar with a bunch of
drunks stumbling into tables and then
darts.
There's another fucking genius idea.
Let's take a bunch of people that are
hammered and give him pointed metal
things to throw at each other.
Help.
They don't cross the line.
It really is a darling.
There's nothing worse than a dart
league.
Especially.
They fight.
They'll fight over a guy's fucking foot
crossing the line.
They'll actually go to blows.
I don't find it enjoyable.
I played dark.
Even if I got them all on the red button
and be like,
who gives a fuck?
Terrible.
I don't enjoy darts.
Do you think if you've tried to pick a
fight with a dark guy,
did they draw on each other?
They pull their darts out,
take three paces or whatever and throw
them at each other.
I was at in a fight a nine to five.
I was at a bar that there was a fight
and somebody took a datsun and stabbed
the guy in the back.
They probably never fight each other for
that reason.
They're all holding darts.
It's like a fucking really.
The store in Texas,
everybody's got a gun.
You don't do it.
Yeah.
That's an interesting way of looking at
it.
You never hear about to dark players
going out and throwing darts at each
other.
You know what I mean?
Like they're really experts at tossing
weapons.
We had darts,
a fucking weapon.
Now you know,
if it was poison,
you're fucked man.
How are you going to stop a dirt from a
dark expert guy?
Was the only thing is they take their
time,
those fucks,
don't you hate when they line.
I hate when they got their foot there
and they got the eye thing and the arms
going back and forth and you're like,
oh,
just fucking kill yourself.
What is the stupid fucking.
If you really stop and think about it,
I mean it's fun to play.
Don't get me wrong,
but what a stupid skill.
So throw something and make it stick
into a wall.
It's something spot.
Something that counted years ago we
hunted for food or like on game of
thrones.
That's a great skill to have to be able
to shoot something accurately at a
target,
but now it just doesn't mean anything
anymore.
Unless you're hunting,
you're going like squirrel hunting with
a bow and arrow.
Yeah.
You have to have a really good aim.
If you're doing something like that was
a dark.
Could you go like bird hunting with a
dark loosening up to these
motherfuckers?
No Way.
Low dark would see he'd blow Darwin
where.
Yeah.
I watched the special with these dudes
were Jack and monkeys with blow darts.
It was really crazy to watch man.
Watching people kill monkeys is very
strange.
I mean it's so.
It feels so close to murder.
It's weird.
You know,
you're like,
man,
a monkey.
You're killing monkeys.
Like those things are really close to
people.
Man.
Shooting Darts at his thing and these
monkeys.
There was a Carrari I think that was the
name of the poison.
There was some sort of a is if my back
or some shit.
Usually frogs.
Motherfuckers,
man.
Yeah.
Well the dues in the Amazon,
they find out everything that kills you
and they take note.
If you ever want to put something on a
spear tip,
that fucking thing will kill you because
they ate it once somebody they know
eight at wanting to drop dead and like
make a note.
She had somebody.
I mean that's the only way they knew.
Yeah.
When you're dealing with like the
Amazon.
Do you ever see that?
The documentary about the guy who swam
through the Amazon,
he swam the length of the Amazon River?
No.
Yeah.
God Damn it.
It's a.
it's a really fascinating.
Let me find God.
Guy Swims.
Amazon,
how many miles with the Amazon
documentary?
A long fucking time.
He got fucked up.
Big River Man.
Yeah,
bits called big river man.
The guy is fucking crazy.
I mean he's crazy.
He drinks beer every night and he gets
in this water and swims for days and he
doesn't even look like he's in the
greatest shape in the world,
but the guy just can go and go and go.
But he's ingesting all this fucking
water and like this parasite written
place and he gets all fucked up from it.
I mean he's really,
really,
really sick and he keeps going.
He keeps going.
Keeps fucking swimming this thing.
I mean,
what,
what he did was pretty fucking
incredible because he was just like a
regular guy who drank beer who decided
to make this happen.
Like I don't think,
you know,
I mean he's,
he would look,
he didn't like you see the way he's
built his building.
I mean it's a sturdy looking fella,
but he's just not built like a guy who's
going to swim the fucking lengthen the
Amazon a couple of years ago.
So I can't remember all the details
about it,
but I remember thinking like what a
crazy character this guy is.
He's been like a fire in the twenties.
It would have had to have had that
barrel chest that you knew that they
would fucking problems,
but they weren't ripped and cut guys are
today.
Well there's a lot of guys today that
are like that.
You know,
looking guy like Mike Russell,
he's a world class heavyweight in the
UFC.
He's knocked out todd Duffy.
He's a big fucking guy,
so Chicago cop,
but he's built like that,
you know,
it's built like a regular guy.
Some people just have a higher level of
fat is just genetically.
There's nothing you can do about that
dude who wants to be punched in the face
by a Chicago cop fighter.
Pleasant.
He's a nice guy too.
They all are that.
The guys are the nicest athletes I've
met.
That's why I love it so much.
Every one of them has been a cool guy
that I've met and interviewed and never
had they been next to us.
Well,
they have a much healthier attitude.
I think that the,
the accolades,
and this is not hating on anybody,
but I think the accolades that a
professional athlete gets almost
unhealthy sometimes.
Yeah.
Yeah,
and I think that they're not getting the
humiliation that fighters get by losing,
by training in the gym,
by,
by getting broken in the gym,
by getting submitted,
by getting tagged.
There's like a certain level of reality
that fighters live in where they don't.
They don't have to engage on this chest
puffing that you see a lot of people
doing almost a compensated because it's
almost like they don't.
They can't even believe that through
this fucking superstar.
So part of their brain is like
sabotaging a course in it,
causing them to act like cons and not
tip anywhere and slammed doors on people
and the kind of shit in here from like
really arrogant pro athletes.
But with MMA fighters for the most part,
these are dudes that if you,
if you're serious about that sport,
you have to have like a spartan
discipline.
I mean,
you have to be the type of person that's
watching your diet,
making sure you're organizing your
training and you just get humiliated.
You get humiliated and humbled is a
better word.
You get humbled by the whole process of
trying to become great and of just
different athletes know,
you see like some,
some pro basketball players that are
like super arrogant or,
or crazy.
It's like you don't see nearly,
you're always gonna see it a certain
amount and the population of people,
but you don't see nearly as much in mma
or in the UFC as you would think.
I haven't met that many NBA people that
I liked.
Um,
to be honest,
the one I thought was really nice.
Clyde frazier we had on it was great.
Uh,
Dr Jay was really nice,
but I think he's lost a lot of the
money.
Um,
but fucking I met Lebron James wants
briefly and he wasn't awful,
but I only got a photo with them.
This is what,
uh,
what,
this is fairly humiliating.
I wanted a picture with him at the
comedy cellar.
So I texted Kevin Hart because they're
good friends.
I'm like,
I want to get a picture with Lebron.
So he texted Lebron,
took my friend's going to be asking you
for a picture.
So that's the only reason he stopped was
because I texted Kevin Hart.
Oh,
well that's a good deal though.
That's a good connection.
Yeah,
it is.
To text my friend who does movies and
see what he can get me a picture of the
fucking NBA player.
Bad favor to call it.
People don't know you like in pictures
with celebrities.
You have like more pictures with
celebrities in any other celebrity.
I do have a lot of them.
Yeah,
and I'm glad I do it.
I,
it's,
it's fun to do.
Although the ones I wished I had,
I got autographs,
but I met kinison wants and didn't get a
photo and prior I met once and didn't
get a photo,
but I didn't do photos back then.
Yeah,
there's a few people that I wish that
I'd taken.
I wish I'd taken a photo with Hicks.
I think that would have been crying.
I never got to meet him.
It was more like a high,
you know,
I never,
I never got to talk to her,
but I got to see him perform a couple of
times when I was an open mic or fa.
If cameras were around back then back
then it was like really rare.
You had a camera on you,
but if cameras around like back then.
Oh,
what a great picture that be.
Yeah.
I never met pillocks.
No ma'am.
I've never listened to her stuff.
Like I've heard cliffs,
we played.
I know and a,
I've never listened to a hick cd and
everyone tells me how great he was,
but it's like at this point in my life,
I just don't want to hear another
comment can be influenced by him.
Like just.
I hear he's great and good.
Good for him and I don't want to know
that.
That's interesting.
Yeah.
You know,
I've had this
conversation before.
We have a different opinion on,
on that.
I hear Ya.
That can can happen,
but I got it.
I like getting inspired and I think for
me the best way to get inspired is by
just listening to comedy.
You know,
I,
I didn't get inspired.
It makes me want to write,
you know,
and I think I just,
I don't feel like there's any sense in
avoiding a certain amount of influence
that we're going to give each other,
but I also think if your mind is
straight and your,
you're good ethics as far as like your
writing,
I don't think you really have to worry
about that.
You know,
what you're doing.
You're trying to pursue your ideas.
You're not trying to pursue somebody
else's.
I think it's a good thing to worry about
when you first starting out,
but I don't think a year years stop.
I don't.
There's no way.
You're very ethical,
you know,
and I respect your take on this opinion,
like the reason why you're doing it.
You're doing it for the exact right
reasons.
I just always feel like,
uh,
I got into comedy because I love the art
form itself and I'm a fan of it and I
don't want to not be a fan of it.
I just,
just because I'm doing it,
it doesn't mean I want to still enjoy it
as if I had nothing to do with it.
If I was never involved,
you know,
if I went on it became a comic book
artist or whatever else I wanted to be
or it could have been if I wasn't a
comic.
I would like to think that I would like
comedy just as much.
Yeah,
you know,
it's funny.
I see like I went into a collins one man
show about the constitution.
How was that?
I heard a great thing.
It's amazing.
And Colin Quinn and where is it?
It's,
it's in New York,
but I think he's moving theaters like
the Cherry Lane theater,
but he might be moving and it's a whole.
I think it's better than his last one,
which I thought was brilliant,
but this one is totally.
It's like stand up,
but it's all about the constitution and
it's fucking.
That's inspiring to see like,
because he never takes the easy road.
Like I buy a column because he never
goes for the easy Dick joke or the cheap
angle.
Like he fucking toughs it out and if
he's bombing on stage at the cellar,
he takes it like a man and he works it
out and he makes it funny,
like he's really,
really,
uh,
just above everybody I think.
And this is,
I put him at the top above all comics to
do an hour on the constitution.
I could do maybe three minutes and I
would immediately go,
I wonder how big Jefferson's thick would
lapse right into the fucking slave
fucking.
But okay,
I'm going to stop you right there.
I think
there's anything wrong with that.
I think what you do,
and I love Khan,
I think Colin is hilarious,
but honestly I'd rather see you.
Thank you.
The reason being is because you're a
fucked up dude and you're going to say
some fucked up shit and it's going to be
fun.
It's going to be,
you're going to say some nutty shit.
Colon talking about the constitution
would be fascinating and I think I enjoy
that.
I completely different level,
but for sheer laughs,
if I'm wanting to just goof on shit,
I would like to see an act like yours.
Thank you,
because because you're having fun,
you know,
and uh,
I think I'm having a show on the
constitution is,
is very,
very difficult,
but it's also very difficult to do a
show the way you're it.
It's
really hard to do what you do.
That's why there's so very few people
who are as honest as you warm when
you're onstage as open about your
perversions and as lovable in,
that's like very difficult to do.
Like you shouldn't sell that short.
Like what you do is just as much of an
art form as what Colin does.
And I would,
I love to see both of them,
don't get me wrong,
but you can't say like,
I,
I enjoy that style of comedy and it's
fucking hard to do.
That's why there's only like at all the
really good dirty comics in this
country,
how many of them are there really?
Or even a dozen.
Is there even a dozen that you would go
out of your way to see at a $300,
million people?
Is there even a dozen really perverted,
dirty guys that you would go say,
no,
it's a fucking.
It's a very difficult thing to cultivate
to get to that point.
You know,
it's,
it's weird.
It's like I don't mind doing dirty
stuff,
like if I'm being truthful,
I just don't like doing it when I know,
like prior said that he said
motherfucker or nigger too much at times
as a crutch and he knew when he was
doing it,
like I don't want to do it as a crutch.
I don't want to like use it as priors.
Motherfucker,
if I'm doing it because I want to do it,
I'm cool with it.
I'll be as filthy as you want to fucking
tranny jokes.
I'll talk about being shit on whatever,
but if I'm doing it because I fuck,
I don't have anything.
Right.
And you know what I mean?
It's like then I feel like I'm doing the
equivalent of a fart sound and it's like
I wish I didn't sell myself.
That is the big leap that you make as a
comic when you get past just doing stuff
that works to doing stuff that you
believe in that and it works because you
believe in it.
It's not like a trick.
It's not like just a feeling that you
get.
When I remember doing material that was
dirty when I was first starting out,
like one of the things that I would
remember is how awkward it was when I
was forcing it when I was like bombing
and I was trying to make like it was
funny.
It wasn't funny.
It was just bullshit.
When you're dirty especially it's like
extra awkward.
Oh,
it's like a giant echo in the room
because you finished with con and you're
like so disappointed in yourself back
then.
I was like always disappointed in myself
that I could never go clean.
So that guy was like,
I could probably have a career.
I thought I could do well as a clean
comic,
but for whatever reason I just wouldn't
do it.
I just didn't.
I was like,
ah,
why can't you just be clean?
So when I would bomb if I bombed dirty
or be like,
Oh God,
yeah,
I'm strict.
Humiliating.
Yeah,
it was clean.
But you know what?
I find that there's.
I don't find any extra valor and
cleanliness.
I mean,
it's a good thing to do if you're really
funny,
clean,
but I think that they both have,
they're both equally acceptable if
they're,
if they're original and funny.
Like I agree with guys that stink and
I'm like,
I don't give a shit.
I hate cute euphemisms and uh,
you know,
then she was giving me a kiss on Mike.
Man Under TV.
You can't say cocker,
I get that right?
But when you're trying to cute it up at
a nightclub,
it makes me,
it physically makes me ill.
I'm embarrassed for comments.
That dude right there be an embarrassing
person to talk to.
Could you imagine how many conversation
with a person like that and you're
sitting down and having a conversation
with the person that is just just goofy
and Dorky and you don't want to talk to
a person who doesn't swear.
No.
Can't tell you like one on one.
Tell me what happened.
So,
and then she's talking to my cock and I
can't believe it's happening.
Yeah.
Tell that.
Say that.
Say that if that happened.
So I know you.
So I get to know you because if you
don't,
if you exclude anything weird or twisted
about yourself,
I've never gonna really,
you know,
you.
Yeah.
You know,
that's hard.
It's hard for people to do.
People don't like to include that and I
understand that I'm in a job and you're
in.
We're in a job where it's a little
easier for us because almost most things
are acceptable in our business.
Like as a comedian,
it's hard as an accountant to walk in
and go,
I fucking went out with this girl and
she's blowing me and I realized she had
a dick but I was high and I let her,
like,
you can't walk into an accounting office
and tell anybody that.
But if you say that as a comic,
everybody's like,
all right,
so uh,
how is the Gig?
And we don't care.
We're hard to shock.
But that you could come to a room full
of comics,
a writer's room and tell that story.
And instantly everybody would be
laughing.
Yeah.
They don't care.
We were harder to surprise and we accept
a lot more and we can speak our mind a
lot more,
but uh,
you know,
there's a line where we know that goes
beyond that where people are just being
unnecessarily adorable and not revealing
and I hate them for it.
I really.
Yeah,
no,
I know what you're saying.
They're,
they're,
they're putting on an act either that or
they're a crazy person.
I think that putting on an act and not
to say everybody has to be a speaking
racially insensitive language would be
this way,
but to judge it like they don't get it.
Like Wiener,
I don't care what the guy does,
but for people,
for men to act like I can't comprehend
taking a picture of my cock and course
you can.
We all understand why he does what he
does know.
A lot of guys will do it.
A lot of guys don't cheat but to,
to act appalled that he wants to get a
dick.
So people were enjoying claiming the
moral high ground,
you know,
they,
they love to.
I think that's going to happen in the
future.
Less and less,
I think as the technology becomes more
intertwined in our lives,
there's going to be less and less
privacy.
There's going to be less and less of
grandstanding or there's going to be
people that do it and get caught like
wiener or Eliot Spitzer is perfect
example.
He was a guy who was the mayor of New
York or the governor of New York and was
arresting prostitution rings but was
also using them like.
It's like one of the craziest ideas ever
and so when you get caught,
nobody's going to feel bad.
Like,
what are you doing man?
Like you,
you,
you didn't just use a prostitute,
you know,
you were arresting them.
You were like shutting down prostitution
rings and then you were using
prostitutes.
Like he can't do that.
Yeah.
It's really,
it's the equivalent of your agent double
dipping that it's immoral on every level
and it's crazy.
It's crazy.
It's crazy to arrest him in the first
place for getting paid to do something
that's perfectly legal to do free.
If they just fucked.
If they just had a website that say,
hey,
let's meet up and fuck.
No one would have a problem with that,
but yeah,
because some money's being exchanged.
What does it really?
Is it a tax issue?
It just then say that's what it is and
let's figure out how to tax it.
Morals.
I think it's their idea of what the
morals are.
Ridiculous.
As soon as it's free,
as soon as it's free and you can do it
and there's no problem whatsoever,
but if you charge money for it,
then all of a sudden it's a.
it's a crime.
That's ridiculous because if somebody
just wanted to fuck if some crazy woman
just wanting to go around town,
Hey,
meet me here,
let's fuck,
and then 10:00
I'm going to meet another guy.
I'm gonna.
Fuck him.
No one can say a Goddamn word.
Right?
But because money's being exchanged,
all the sudden she's a criminal.
It's terrible.
And I believe I'm a big fan of
legalizing prostitution.
Well,
it should be legal.
It should.
It shouldn't be mandatory,
but it should be legal.
You should be able to do whatever you
want to do.
It'd be safer.
It was illegal and I think a lot of our
ideas about it,
look,
obviously I don't want my daughters to
be prostitutes,
don't get me wrong,
but I think a lot of our ideas of what's
so horrible about prostitution is all
based on this puritanism bullshit that
we've been pushing this country from the
Gecko.
It's nothing wrong with being nice.
There's nothing wrong with having
morals,
but when you push your own bullshit on
other people and arrest them for giving
hand jobs,
you know,
can you imagine?
You can rub your feet,
you could rub my feet to the cows,
come home,
you could rub my ass cheeks.
That's all good.
But it feels too good when he rubbed my
deck.
So don't do that.
Put you in a cage.
You just have to have food involved.
Pretty much like you have to give him a
sandwich first and like,
look,
I gave you food.
Let's go back to my place.
What's the difference between a date
and,
and you know you're spending $100 on a
date or $100.
Just hair didn't have the money.
It's the,
your,
your.
Although you're spending money,
you're spending money to try to show the
woman that you are a generous person,
you want to take care of her,
and then the sex is a mutual thing.
The idea is just that the men should be
paying for the woman because they're not
worth as much,
which I agree with what?
I agree.
Yeah.
Look,
it's way easy for a girl yet laid.
That is for a guy just so you got to pay
for dinner as seems like they have the
upper hand.
Socially.
It's pretty obvious.
Exactly.
And paper,
fucking dinner buddy walks in with a
pussy on this leg and even then you
gotta fucking smell your buddy's brad
neck.
Yeah,
you're fucking working all over your
carpet.
Your buddies squirt.
Not Hot at all.
You know if your girls squirts all of
your,
your couch doesn't bother you.
Throw a towel down.
If I came over into and while I was
fucking your leg,
clear blitz.
What of genetic engineering leads to
that dude?
Just start putting vaginas on their
elbows.
Bang each other's forearms.
I mean,
that's gonna be someone's going to offer
that option.
If option becomes available,
someone's going to be the guy who gets a
vagina on his thigh.
Absolutely.
It's going to happen.
Yeah.
And his friend will fuck it at a party
and all of a sudden we all start getting
yeast infections in our legs.
Did you hear that?
Eric Holder said today that they need to
stop arresting people for petty
marijuana crimes and crimes where,
uh,
there's no victims or whether it's not a
connection to a drug cartels,
like it's like sort of snuck in under
the radar,
but that's a gigantic statement from the
attorney general that they're going to
like basically stopped this,
this aspect of the drug war.
They want to let people out of jail or
prisons or fucking overcrowded,
like this is two things in the last week
that had been really surprising.
The Sanjay goop does CNN thing where
he's coming out with a documentary on
CNN called weed,
uh,
a year long investigation to the
positive benefits of medical marijuana
and all these people that are sick and
all the different things that it cures
all the different ailments that
alleviates symptoms and this guy is like
coming out and putting out this big
piece on CNN.com.
And the special saying I was wrong.
Like for years I believed mainstream
America,
his opinion about marijuana,
it was a bunch of lazy slackers and I
thought that most of the medical
marijuana was just people trying to get
high.
But now he realizes it's not.
And it's like there's massive,
massive medical benefits.
Losing power.
My Di Lithium crystals,
I think they're getting ready to attend.
I think they're getting ready to go.
Our captain,
it seems like it.
That's what I'm saying.
If CNN puts it on tv like that,
I mean that's pretty crazy.
And then Eric holder saying we need to
stop arresting people for petty crimes
that don't involve drug cartels and
marijuana offenses.
Like what?
Wait a minute.
That isn't that like 50 percent of the
prison because the problem is nonviolent
drug offenders or a giant part of what's
in the prison system and making people
much more likely to continue being
criminals.
Like once you start putting people in
jail,
that's when they're much more likely to
start repeating crimes.
The idea of punishing people by putting
them in jail doesn't really scares the
shit out of 'em.
And if they're smart,
they don't do it again,
but it also introduces them to a bunch
of other people that are fucking
criminals and they all get together and
they talk and they figured out what the
fuck they're going to do together and
once they get out of there,
and that's a way of turning a person who
just wants to sell something that should
be legal into a fucking criminal by
putting them in a cage.
And what else in there?
Figuring that out.
This is crazy.
Yeah.
The government always seems to be a few,
a little behind on the,
uh,
on uh,
you know,
they're,
they're always the last ones to show up
and say yes to something or no,
they have to cover every angle at it and
they have to realize that they can't
control it and then they have to figure
out how to make money off it.
Yeah.
But this is a,
this seems like a shift.
It seems like a shift in,
in just the way they communicate about
it.
Um,
I mean these are new reforms aimed at
curbing US prison population.
There's a big article,
the Guardian about this.
This is a pretty crazy shit
that the tobacco company,
I can't even talk to a company probably
went to the government was like,
look,
we're losing shitloads of money because
you're doing your fucking our crops up
and you know,
making cigarettes so bad.
We want to get into this weed game and
you know,
maybe that's like a way for Marlboro and
all these companies to keep a keep
alive.
Well,
it's not just that.
It's also the projected revenue tax
revenue from legalizing marijuana is
giant.
It's billions in every state.
I mean it's the projected tax revenue.
It sounds so crazy,
but it's really true.
It could fix the United States economy.
That sounds fucking nuts,
but it really could.
There's so much money involved in
marijuana and right now it's all
slipping through the cracks.
It's all going on either illegally or
its state as a medicinal sort of a
thing,
and then they get eventually busted by
the dea because it's not federal.
If they ease up that it changes our
whole culture,
it's going to change everything at once.
People realize all the things you can do
with marijuana that don't involve
getting high when you,
when they realize that the benefits of
Hamp,
which has been illegal forever in this
fucking country since the 19 thirties,
as long as marijuana has been illegal,
we can't grow hemp and the non
psychoactive form of marijuana,
so the stocks of marijuana make it
insanely good paper.
They make tremendous building materials
that are biodegradable and lasts forever
and are stronger than steel.
It's really,
it's a funny fucking plan,
like it's got essential amino acids in
it.
You can eat the protein from it because
it gets you higher.
No.
Oh,
we can get you high,
but mean the stock,
the stock doesn't know.
I mean if you get the female flowers or
we get you high,
so what you're getting when you get him,
it's you're either getting various
strains which which are like we would,
I think technically you wouldn't refer
to it as a cousin,
but it does get referred to as a cousin
all the time,
but people correct me online,
so just that caveat,
but it's essentially the male version of
the plant and variations of the male
versions of the plant and that doesn't
have any psychoactive properties to it,
but you can make fucking ridiculously
strong rope with it.
Like it's a weird plan.
Like you'll take a stock of this stuff.
Right?
I've seen it like this thick is light
like styrofoam but hard as a fucking
rock.
It's weird.
It's a weird fucking plant.
It's like no plant that exists on earth.
It's really almost like it's an alien.
It's such a strange plant and it's so
beneficial to humankind.
The fact that it's illegal is I'm just
outside of the psychoactive effects,
if it had no effect on the human body
whatsoever,
just for,
it's your ability to use in building
materials,
the ability to make clothes and paper
and oil and Henry Ford's first fucking
car had him,
the,
uh,
all of the body panels were made out of
hemp and it ran on hemp.
Like he would make oil from hemp and run
engines
on it.
I mean,
you can do so much shit with it.
It's,
it's almost a joke,
like if you look at all the different
things you could do with it and how
could it be legal?
How could it be illegal?
Rather you wonder why there are certain
things like I wonder why we can't go to
Cuba.
There are certain things that government
does that a get a point.
It's like,
what the fuck are you doing?
Like after awhile it's like enough is
enough of these little things like why
can't I do that?
I'm not a baby.
We're not babies.
And I think that's what these things are
realizing.
There's a push by the American people
and there's a transparency that the
American people are demanding and under
the weight of things like Edward Snowden
and uh,
Bradley manning you all these,
these documents that to get it released
where people are seeing the actual inner
workings of the government,
they have to make some radical reform if
they want to keep a hold of us because
there's a lot of people that are upset
right now finding out about the NSA,
watching every single American is if
we're all bad.
But how about all of us?
Who Do?
Can I,
can it be like the Tsa?
Can I get up to tsa pre where you know
that I'm not a fucking terrorist.
So you stop reading my email Dick.
Juan,
can I.
can we make that deal?
I have mixed feelings about the NSA.
I am a part of me loves that they did
that because the American people have
become such.
What bothers me about Americans is we
become such nosy pigs into each other's
lives and there's nothing in American
loves more than violating the privacy of
somebody else.
True.
Nothing we love more.
And now all of the sudden we don't like
it because someone's invading our
privacy.
Like I believe I get the difference of
the government doing.
It's awful.
But I mean just the principle of it
where all these fucking people.
I've said this before,
crying about privacy when they couldn't
get enough of Mel Gibson's private voice
mails or Alec Baldwin's phone calls or
our tiger woods is private texts.
Now I understand.
We look at them as entertainment value,
but people also are comfortable seeing
those things and making judgements and
treating people a certain way because of
them.
So they didn't give a fuck that anybody
else's privacy was violated.
However,
their privacy is sacred.
So I kind of like Google glass and I
liked this.
It evens the playing field.
Just,
you know,
like fucking does portray us.
The head of the CIA.
I couldn't fuck some chick on the side
when he's married to Michael Moore.
How depressing is that?
And no one gets away with anything
anymore.
So I wish the American people would stop
being so nosy and minding everyone's
business but their own.
And I would completely be against the
NSA,
but until that happens,
fuck them.
I love the fact that their privacy is
being violated to and they can see how
it feels.
Wow.
That's an angry Jimmy Norris.
Not even angry.
Just tired of not.
I'm not even mad at,
but I know what you're saying.
I agree with you to a certain extent
that self righteousness that people
have.
Like with Paula Deen,
they're comfortable allowing her to be
lynched publicly and no one is stepping
up and going,
you know what I've said some shitty
things.
No one expresses that honesty in
themselves and give each other breaks on
inappropriate things that we say or a
little.
We're allowing moments
to define who people are and we all have
the moments.
Yes,
it's,
it's nuts.
And we might not have the moments to the
that varying.
Exactly that.
The degree of,
of fucked up attitude.
You know,
like I know she did a lot of.
I don't know what Paula Dean actually
did,
but if you listen to what the people
that work with her,
she sounds like she was a funny racist,
old white lady.
I don't know,
I wouldn't,
I wouldn't want to even guess of what it
would be like to be a black guy working
for her and hearing that shit coming out
of her mouth work though.
I don't know if she did or supposedly
allegedly,
who the fuck knows?
I mean,
that's what I read.
That's what people were accusing her of.
Unless you're there,
who knows?
In your.
You're also dealing with disgruntled
employees.
Wins.
Paul Dean winds the resource suit that
destroyed her.
How does she win?
See her black friends that she hangs out
with?
Oh,
she's got black friends.
No big black guy with the hat.
It's probably gonna fucking cock.
What is the,
uh,
the,
the judgment.
What does it say?
Uh,
it says that,
uh,
the,
the original lawsuit,
a judge ruled that Lisa Jackson had no
right to claim racial discrimination
because she's white.
Any comments that dean or her cohorts
may have had had no legal consequences.
Oh,
so she tried to claim rakes,
racial discrimination,
and she was white.
She was just trying to get paid.
Yeah.
Dirty can't.
So,
but she destroyed Paula.
Dean's pretty much
Yam.
Nah,
she'll be fine.
She's ruined.
You think so?
Because again,
no one.
You see Matt Lauer that fucking just bag
sanctimonious interview he did with her.
Yeah.
That wasn't nice,
but he couldn't like where was this?
Where was one ounce of honesty and this
guy like,
maybe you've never said that word,
but are you going to tell me you've
never in your life under oath,
you could say you've never said a
racially insensitive thing.
Bullshit.
Yeah.
I think he's got a problem and his
problem is that he's.
He's a talking head on the inner on
television who's not allowed to have
anything even remotely controversial
come out of his mouth and he's also
terrified because he's in that box.
So for him to like try to.
First of all,
you can't do that in a little
conversation.
If you're going to have a conversation
with that woman about the world,
about racism,
you're going to have to sit down with
her like this.
You're going to have to podcast.
We'll have a three hour conversation
with her.
Find out who are you,
what,
what did you do,
like your giving and you'll know by the
end of three hours whether or not she's
full of Shit.
Yeah,
you will.
You'll know everyone will be able to.
You could bullshit your way through a
five minute conversation on the tonight
show.
You can't bullshit your way through
three hours,
not at all,
and I think this is an issue that really
needed to be addressed like that.
It's can't like have a quick Matt Lauer
interview with this scared lady in a
scared old lady that has fucking death
threats coming in from black people all
day.
I'm sure you know you can't.
You can't be a white person in 2013
calling people niggers phony,
phony outrage and studied with within
black people who get annoyed.
It is
when I've grown to hate his other white
people.
Patrice said it,
Patrice said it best.
He goes,
I've never met a racist.
Not One person I've ever admitted
admitted has ever admitted they were
racist.
And what I hate about these fucking
these white people whose idea of
combating racism is just targeting other
white people who have said something
inappropriate is simply their way of
deflecting attention from themselves and
their own.
I think they have superiority complexes
and I think like I can't walk up to my
black friends and tell them,
hey,
I'm not a racist.
But if Paula deen acts like one,
then I can use her to mirror how good I
am.
It's a self serving proposition and I
hate it and I don't buy it.
I just don't buy it,
man.
Yeah,
I agree with you that there's a lot of
people that love to do that moral high
ground.
Yes.
They loved by not by telling you that
you're doing something wrong.
They're not just telling you that you're
doing something wrong.
They're telling you that they're
awesome.
Yes.
That's a big thing.
And it's in their tone and it's in their
lack of the lack of self revealing they
do in these moments and in these
discussions,
if they revealed ugliness about
themselves,
I would have respect for them.
Like,
why am I comfortable talking about a
paddle,
Brian's dirty voicemails or tiger woods
is dirty text messages because I talk
about my own,
like I'll make fun of his,
but I'll tell you that I,
I also have texted my cock to many
people.
I'm a piece of shit so I'm not coming.
I'm not better than him and I refuse to
come off like that.
Yeah,
there's a real problem with people
thinking that you need to be better than
people too.
It's like especially pretending that
should never work.
So claiming the moral high ground and
becoming the super white knight and
pretending that you know,
you're there to defend all women.
It's this shit doesn't work.
It never works because the type of women
you get from faking that shit.
I mean,
you might really be that guy and if you
are,
God bless you.
But if you're faking it well,
who's going to trick one average girl
with glasses and a stupid tattoo with
words on her arm,
fucking blow fucking baggy jeans.
You're not going to get much out of it.
Have you ever banged a feminist?
Um,
I'm sure I have,
um,
you know,
uh,
yeah,
I've banged some very was I liked strong
women a lot.
I don't like I'm strong.
Yes.
I like that type of woman a lot.
A lot of them are sexually submissive,
like lawyers that I've fucked up in
sexual submissive female cops because
they're very strong and uh,
you know,
they liked something different.
You all,
I'm sure,
but I have nothing against the feminist
if she's reasonable and she's fighting
for women to get what they deserve,
I'm for it when the language police and
they nitpick because their causes not as
needed as it was 20 years ago.
Then I hate their guts like any other
special interest group,
but when they're fighting for what's
right and legitimately getting the right
amount of money and be like,
I don't think women should be sexually
harassed at work.
Like these guys had like this fucking
cock sucker in San Diego who's grabbing
women and being a complete of shit and
saying he didn't know.
Fuck that guy.
Like one of those women's husbands
should fucking hit this guy with an ax.
Yeah.
He would be hard to imagine your wife
being at work with some latch all day
was like constantly harassing him,
bothering her and brushes or cock buyer
when she walks by her in the hall,
you know,
that kind of shit that happens to people
at work and people go,
look,
I was just walking by and then what's
the big people are always being.
Yep.
But that's a can.
It doesn't matter if he's a man or a
woman,
you know?
I think,
uh,
I think the idea of feminism is a good
idea as the idea of masculinism that's a
good idea to.
I want to think it's a real word,
but if it was a real word to be a good
idea,
there's nothing,
there's nothing wrong with you being
allowed to be you and me being allowed
to be me and we're going to be fucking
different.
That's why the world varies so much.
That's why movies,
very music varies.
It's stand up.
Comedy varies.
There's people that like all kinds of
different shit,
but a lot of men don't want women to be
women and a lot of women don't want men
to be men.
They want them to be what they want them
to be and when,
when you have,
when you have some asshole who wants you
to be a certain way and you have to work
for that Dick and you're a woman,
that's a special place in hell.
I mean,
that's a fucking horrible place in hell,
but it has nothing to do with this.
It's not a sex thing.
It's not an all gender thing.
He said,
that guy's a piece of shit.
Yeah.
Here's a picture.
You just found a piece of shit.
It just happens to be a man,
but guess what?
If you're a man and you have a boss and
your boss is a woman and she's a fucking
asshole.
I have a friend who has a woman ball.
Yeah.
He actually just left his Gig,
but he had this woman boss.
We brutalized him.
Just wouldn't,
just wouldn't leave them alone.
It was just like giving them cancer,
just like rotting Adam,
like all day,
every day with someone who you couldn't
talk back to who was just fucking with
you in pastoring you and B rating you
and insulting you and there's not a damn
thing you can do to take it.
Not a damn thing you can do about.
She was talking to him in a way that a
regular man would never like a man in
the street that did,
you didn't owe anything to,
would never talk to you when she was
ready to fight.
Yeah.
But she would just get in his face and
pointed him and say crazy shit to him.
Has nothing to do now and there's
nothing to get done and that's why she's
doing it.
Yeah.
I mean she would ask him if he was
stupid.
Are you stupid?
Like in like,
wow,
I have to listen to this.
You know,
and there's nothing you can do about it.
You're just stuck.
That shouldn't be right.
And it shouldn't be right for any human
being to do that to another human being,
should have said stupid,
is as stupid does,
and then given a khaki look.
So in that sense,
yeah,
I'm a feminist and a lot of ways on
masculinity.
So I'm a humanist.
I think we should be able to do whatever
we want.
The problem is when you start looking
out for your own,
when you start looking out for a gender
or a generalization,
you start going towards one gender only
emphasizing that one.
Gender inequities,
inadequacies in our society.
The problem is you become a gang and you
become a part of a team.
Right?
But the thing is,
is that what I hate about people much as
they say,
uh,
because they're,
they're not consistent.
Like I don't.
Everything should be the same.
And I don't want.
Nothing should be different unless
you're talking about diversity,
then it's good.
I don't like any kind of profiling.
It's wrong,
unless of course it's a,
it's an ethnic pride parade,
then we can all profile.
It's a delightful idea.
I'd be proud to be Irish.
So people only want grand sweeping
generalizations when they're a part of a
good grand sweeping generalization,
if they're a part of it.
Like it's funny,
I go through TSA security and they're
now saying anybody under 12 or over 75
does not have to take your shoes off.
And I have not heard one person
complaining about age discrimination.
I'm over 75.
Why am I not being treated the same as
these other people?
I have not heard one fucking parent
saying,
my kids under 12.
Why aren't you treating them like
everybody else?
It's only when we're treated in a manner
that we don't approve of,
that we take this principle of,
hey,
don't treat me differently.
It's,
it's,
it's arbitrary and it's bullshit.
So that's why you can't respect any of
it.
Makes me crazy.
Yeah.
I'm not a big fan of groups.
Um,
I'm really not a big fan of groups have
focused on one gender.
I'm a big fan of generalizations.
I'm not a big fan of a lot of things.
I'm certainly not a big fan of anything
where anyone who is the weaker is
getting bullied.
Whether it's physical,
whether it's a sexual thing or physical
thing,
or a man bugging a woman,
a sister.
I have daughters.
I have a wife,
I I 100 percent.
No,
it's way more difficult to be a woman
than it is to be a man in the physical
sense and I think there should be laws
about that shit abso-fucking-lutely.
I think that men who do abuse women or
who do sexually harassing their fucking
creepy people are tripping but so are
women who do it too,
man.
And the idea that that's not the case.
The,
the idea that a situation where a man
who gets taken by a woman in a divorce
and some fucking horrible way where you
know,
you find.
I mean,
I could go into this for days,
but I'm sure we all know guys who just
been raped and divorce.
Some of us do radio.
What day?
Yeah.
Anthony got murdered.
I know some.
I know a guy who lost millions.
I know my favorite story.
I even talked about them on my act.
He had to pay for his wife's attorney
and his wife dragged the thing out for
years.
So he is paying for the enemy's general,
so he's going to war for all of his
money and he winded up costing him
everything.
I mean it was just a devastating several
year event that she wouldn't.
She was doing it on purpose to try to
drag it out and to try to milk him.
When you see some shit like that,
you think like,
okay,
men should have rights to.
Okay.
Yes,
absolutely.
He's not in a sense it's not the same
thing as him being raped.
Absolutely.
But he's being financially destroyed and
he's.
Someone's doing it in a spiteful way
when they're doing it because they just
grew to hate him or whatever the fuck it
was.
But there should be a law against that.
Like they didn't even have children.
Like it was one of the craziest things
I've ever seen in my life.
When you find out what happens if a man
and woman are together for x amount of
years,
then he has to pay for her for the rest
of her life.
Yeah.
But he doesn't get the fucker.
That's the beautiful part.
Like she's like,
well I have a lifestyle.
He said,
well,
I was expecting I,
I was used to getting blown and having
your ass in my face.
How about that?
What we're used to remember Chris Rock's
bit about that,
you know about alimony and pussy
payments.
Yeah,
he had it.
He had a whole book,
a book about it,
like I believe in Amway,
but I also believe in pussy payments.
Yeah.
This,
you know,
there's all sorts of inequality in this
world of both projected towards women
and projected towards men and there's
all sorts of assholes in the world,
both women and men.
There's just assholes and that's a real
problem in this life.
It's not lumping ourselves into groups
and generalizing that all women are good
and all men are bad or vice versa.
That's crazy too.
What's what's important is recognizing
that there's really only three types of
people in the world.
Morons,
assholes,
and people that are all right.
You know,
you might not agree with them.
You might not like them.
You might.
They might not be your style.
They might be different.
Morons,
assholes,
and people that are all right.
That's really all there is in this
world.
We're also paying for the sins of a lot
of other people for centuries,
let's,
you know,
white American men dominated everything
in this country and then like,
you know,
there's also a reality of a lot of
people were treated like garbage for a
long time and a lot of promises were
broken and there's a reality to that
that's not excuse making,
it's not,
it's a real thing.
And then they say,
well,
you know,
white people have benefited from that
system.
Even.
So what's happening is in an effort to
balance the playing field a little bit,
a lot of us today are being treated
unfairly because the balancing act is
making things go so far.
And like I do understand that.
That's why I had a conversation after a
Tosh is uh,
uh,
and who did they get,
oh,
Tracy's gay jokes.
And I had to come from folks that don't
know Tracy Morgan did a joke about if
his son was gay,
he would stab them.
And everybody went crazy.
And I had a couple of gay comics on Rick
Chrome and Jim David and we talked about
this on this comedy special.
I did,
and uh,
the as Comedians,
I asked them how do they feel about the
imbalance in the language,
like the fact that you get in trouble
for that now.
And Jim David said,
I'm okay with it and uh,
I'm like,
well,
how are you okay with it as a comic?
And he goes,
because it's not a level playing field,
meaning what he thought was like in
life,
gay people had not treated as well,
so he didn't give a shit if,
if that guy got in a little bit more
trouble and I kind of,
I heard what he said.
They're like,
even though I don't want to get in
trouble for it,
in that sense,
he was right.
It's like,
you know,
we still have a big segment of our
country that can't get married and
they're treated like second class
citizens,
but yet we go around and tell other
countries had to live their lives.
Which soulfully shit.
It makes me nuts.
Well,
I think that there's a real legitimate
argument in the idea that until it
balances out,
until everyone completely relaxes on
discrimination
towards gays,
like,
like there's no discrimination on
bachelors anymore,
you know,
like of a man as a 50 year old man,
he says,
I'm just not getting married again.
There no discrimination or social,
not a social pariah,
but if he decides to marry a man than it
is like,
well what?
Well,
what is that and why is that not
eradicated from our culture yet?
Well,
once that is eradicated from our
culture,
then I think people are going to be much
more likely to accept gay jokes much
more like.
Because I keep hearing that gay jokes or
homophobic and I'm like,
guess what?
No,
they're not.
It's not homophobic at all.
It's a gay joke.
Just like jokes about straight sex
aren't heterophobia alright.
They're jokes about sex and there's,
there's jokes about everything and it's
really about context.
It's not about the subject matter and
you can't eliminate certain subject
matters.
You just can't because the human
language is very nuance.
There's a lot of shit going on and every
single interaction that you have we're
humor could potentially be crafted from.
It can be taken into a whole wide
variety of different ways and I like all
of those ways.
I like people saying fucked up shit.
They don't really mean.
I think there's something funny and
Tracy Morgan saying if a funnel,
most of them with girls I.
and it's ridiculous.
It's ludicrous,
right?
It's not real.
Of course he wouldn't do that.
Of course it would be,
you know,
it's,
it's ridiculous.
The idea that it's like,
I do a joke in my Mac,
like guess what?
Johnny cash didn't really shoot a man in
Reno just to watch them die either.
Maybe it's,
I don't think he did.
He might be more likely that he did it.
Then Tracy Morgan would stab his son.
Stupid Johnny.
Johnny.
Johnny cash probably should have said I
took some pills and fell asleep on the
tour bus.
That might be more accurate,
but I get what we're gay people are
coming from too though,
because it's not a level playing field.
So when you see like all this,
like it's almost like shitting on people
when they're down.
Like,
here's a perfect example,
like um,
this,
this opioid thing that's going on with
uh,
if you don't know ob many years ago
stomped on his homeless guys cake and he
thought it would be cute to put it
online and people are so fucking mad at
them because it's a really douchey thing
to do.
It's been online for years though.
He just retweeted it.
I think it's two for seven years.
But the fact that he will,
what people didn't like,
his people have a sense of humanity and
they look at this guy and he's a
homeless guy.
He's fucking down and out and here's
this millionaire radio dj who thinks
it's funny to stomp on his cake.
Like,
you know what I mean?
In that context.
Like I.
and that's something that unfortunately
you can't,
like what would,
how we would do a walk over from Iraq
everyday,
which you did with us.
And that guy was,
that was Andrew and he was the guy we
saw everyday.
He was a guy we talked to.
We had on the air,
we gave money to them.
We would give them food,
like we had a really good relationship
with this guy.
I think that's why he was offering cake
because we had stopped by so many times
and handed him food.
He had some cake and open a dick thing,
but it was just.
It was literally just to make everybody
laugh.
It wasn't to dehumanize this guy or to
degrade
him.
It was something he would have done to
anybody else that he knew and I know
that that made people go well too,
but the reality was the context of that
relationship with Andrew,
the homeless guy was not some,
hey bomb,
here's some money.
We can do what we want.
It didn't feel like that.
It didn't come off like that one.
I really depressed after stomped.
Just started drinking again too.
We were trying to get him sober and a
good way to do it.
Well,
you know,
there's a piece of shit cake.
Anyway,
it was a fucking garbage.
I see you're supporting oprah and I'm
friends with too.
I'm supporting opiod only because I was
there through that entire walk over with
Andrew and I saw him 50 times before and
after that.
So in context,
yeah,
I would have been fucking.
It was.
It was cringy and I was like,
Oh God.
Did he give him anything after he
stumped on this cake to give them any
money?
Of course he did.
We gave him anything.
He,
I'm like $100 and then people will
going.
That wasn't good enough.
I feel like this is what I'm saying.
They're like,
oh,
you could to humanize them and give him
100 bucks.
But it wasn't looked at like nobody felt
like wow,
he dehumanized this guy because he was
somebody we talked to all the time and
had great interactions with.
So that's why it didn't feel like I
understand people seeing it though and
going home like the fuck is going on you
piece of shit.
Like I get seeing a one and a half
minute clip.
Maybe I would feel the same way if I
didn't have the luxury of having been
there throughout that entire time.
We'll what we see.
Here's a perfect example.
If if that homeless guy was getting in
an argument with another homeless guy
and the homeless guy jumped on his cake,
then it would be okay because there's
one homeless guy getting over on another
homeless guy and stomp on kick,
but when a millionaire guy does it,
look,
I know what he was doing and I know what
that that audience is like when you're.
When you guys are opie and Anthony is my
favorite show ever to do because it's
such a hang and everybody's making
everybody else laugh and it's like what
we were talking about before the show
today.
It's like what?
What's okay for you and I to talk about
in our jobs,
like I stand up comedians for most
people that,
that those same words and thoughts would
get you fired,
will get you kicked out of the office.
You get written up,
you can get sued.
You can't have that sort of mentality.
But for us it's so normal.
So when you're hanging out with opie and
Anthony [inaudible] and you guys are
just talking mad shit and you're on the
air as you're walking across the street
and you're just trying to make each
other laugh.
And one of the things that people do
when they try to make each other laugh
is it crossed the line.
They're completely brutally crossed the
line and that's the way to do that.
They're brutally crossed the line.
You've got to jump on the homeless guys,
cake and Opie in doing that,
it sounds like a cop out on my part
because he's my friend and I would never
have done what he did,
but I know what his motivation was.
It was exactly.
And your audience will accept a lot,
but honestly there is a humanity to
them.
Like that homeless shopping spree we
would do.
The homeless guys would never mistreat.
Like they were treated like rock stars.
They would go to the mall,
thousands of people would be cheering
them,
buying them shit with their people.
We had
gotten to know.
So it was like the people who mentioned,
oh,
then they would do the homeless shopping
spree.
It's like they weren't.
It didn't feel like,
oh my God,
it felt like a fucked up thing to do,
but it didn't feel as literal as,
oh my God,
he's a millionaire stepping on the food
of a homeless man,
because I don't think that was the
intent behind it other than just being a
dick in that moment to a guy who he knew
we had given food money to and we were
going to give money to the.
It's like,
I know what you're saying.
I know it was just a momentary dick
thing to do.
And he did it in the sense of humor.
It's silly not to humiliate Andrew.
Nobody wanted to hear.
The problem is when you see things out
of context,
it's like you were talking about earlier
about Paula Dean,
you don't know the entirety of a person
when you see one event is a great guy.
We had him on the podcast,
he's a great guy.
And I,
uh,
I always credit you guys with being the
reasons.
One of the reasons why I wanted her to
get into podcasting in the first place,
it was because of doing your show
because your show was the only show that
I had ever done where it was just no,
there was no like rigid set of like,
this is this now and then we're going to
go to the wacky five at five and then
there's bomb on the chopper.
There was nothing.
It was a hang.
It was a complete total hang.
Every time I've ever done it,
whether it's with [inaudible] or with.
I mean fucking how many times have I
done it?
I've done it so many times with so many
different comics with rich or with never
cut a deal with patrice.
The only thing I did with Patrice was
when we did that thing in vegas
together,
which was a lot of.
Oh Wow.
Yeah,
that's all I got to hang with.
Patrice is the only time I really got to
hang with them outside of like seeing
them early on in the day when I didn't
even know him.
He was one of my favorite people even
though he was very dominating and with
no one could out Yap and Patrice
loudness,
but he was so much fun to do radio with
like he was one of my favorite guys ever
because to make him like if you made him
laugh,
he,
you knew you were funny.
He didn't give it to people for no
reason.
He didn't get pity bullshit fee and he
was just too unconcerned with hurting
people's feelings to do that.
He didn't care.
Um,
and one of my favorite things with him
as I convinced him that face officers
shitty movie and that's one of my,
it's one of my favorite moment.
It happened to k rock.
It was John Travolta and Nick K,
Nick Cage,
who he was arguing he loved that.
He loved it and I fucking convinced,
but it was a fun,
friendly to watch him go like,
ah,
like to see him.
He made me.
It was one of my favorite moments of all
time in that,
just to see this,
this because he was such a giant of a
guy intellectually,
like the greatest mistake people could
make with patrice fifth to think,
oh,
he's a big black guy.
Patrice was a brilliant motherfucker and
could outtalk almost anybody and could
out logic almost.
So when you,
when you had moments like that,
it was friendly,
you know,
it wasn't like an aggressive argument.
You're like,
God,
that just was one of the most satisfying
moments in my career.
Yeah.
Well,
it's the opportunity to be around fun
people like that rare human beings that
you don't necessarily come across and
you have a regular job.
If you're working as a,
an insurance salesman.
How many patrice o'neal's do you come
across in your life that you get to hang
out with?
Just by calling so late on their
payments?
Quite,
quite a few.
I think one more thing,
by the way,
before I forget,
I wanted to say about ob to,
uh,
about homeless is a,
you know,
he's the one,
not that it matters,
but he's the guy that pushed homeless,
mustered through the Daniel Mustard and
a and tried to get a recording contract
and like really try to take care of the
guy that's the guy singing that song
creep,
really talented,
talented,
but it's like an opie took a real
concern with him in his sobriety.
And again,
I'm not saying people don't get,
I'm not trying to say don't be mad,
be mad,
but again,
don't think you understand the totality
of a guy because he did one silly thing
in a different context to make his radio
guys.
And some fans laugh.
You're so good at breaking shit down.
Dude.
You,
you said that there was not a hint of
bias there.
You were being completely honest about
it.
That's,
I really value that in the way you talk.
And that's why I was really happy when I
watched that Kamau bell show will come
out about I totally biased command,
which was web model w Kamau Bell,
you and Lindy West,
Lindy West who's a,
a feminist blogger for a Jezza bell,
which is a feminist website.
And what I loved about it,
man was first of all,
you never got upset you,
you were rational and logical and you
had,
you were talking about it in a very
measured way and you're being really
friendly while you were discussing this
and you know,
in her,
in her defense,
it's a very tricky subject to breach for
a woman.
And she was saying a lot of shit like
comedy clubs are filled with rooms
filled with angry men.
And you didn't,
you didn't even flinch.
He didn't,
he didn't go after her,
you know,
like she had like these digs about like,
you're allowed to just joke about it,
but I'm allowed to tell you you're a
dick.
Yeah.
I didn't get personally could.
I didn't think she liked.
She hadn't.
The blog wasn't about me.
It was about a guy who,
one guy making a Dick joke or certain
rape jokes that put,
and this is the tricky part of Lindy
West,
he's a lot of people would say she's
against she's presenting ship,
but she really wasn't.
She was about.
She didn't like the jokes that she
thought minimalize the victim in a rape
right now.
It's hard to logically say,
well,
yeah,
minimalizing,
the victim of rape is a good thing,
but what people forget,
they went after Sam morale.
A lot of jokes or just Mrs.
He's a comedian in New York who had done
something like domestic violence jokes
or whatever,
but in a misdirection joke you you go
for the most obvious.
We're opposite thing,
so sometimes it is a violent sometimes
like I did one joke and this didn't come
up in that show,
but like I was talking about seeing it a
girl now I don't know if she had a good
time what was raped at a Porta potty.
I'm not going to go through the whole
joke before,
but those were.
It was at a concert and outdoor concert.
So the two most opposite things I could
think of if I said I didn't know if she
had a good time,
we're not a very good time.
Who gives a shit?
Fuck.
You raped in a Porta potty.
Painting a picture.
If I said I didn't know if she was
beaten in Porta potty or raped in a
Porta potty,
nobody would've laughed because they're
too close.
So the fact I.
I'm explaining this to the audience,
not just the fact that you take two
things that are such polar opposites.
Sometimes the polar opposite you land on
for the joke is a horrible thing that
minimalizes the victim and every
Catholic priests joke is somehow
minimalizing the victim part.
Comedy does that and I don't believe
that it has to just be speaking truth to
power.
I think that's part of it,
but I think that as long as your
intention is genuinely to be funny and
not to humiliate a person for real,
I think it's allowable and it has to be
because it gets to be too subjective
after that.
Well,
it's an art form and if you don't like
that art form,
I completely and totally understand that
you don't have to participate to
participate in the shelves.
You don't have to go,
but when you're,
you're being hypercritical about and
trying to get people to stop doing it,
you're going to make it so that that art
form is not available.
Like the really fucked up thing that you
don't mean art form is not available.
Just like rap music.
I mean,
what is going on in rap music or they're
really running around killing people and
selling cocaine every day.
No,
most of what they're doing is talking
shit about something.
It's no different than the movie
scarface.
Nobody really died in that movie.
Okay.
You're,
you're painting a picture.
It's a gross,
horrific picture,
but some people like that.
They liked to watch scarface,
that liked to listen to rap music.
They want to hear a dirty comic say
horrendous inappropriate things that are
fucked up.
One of my favorites is Otto,
Otto and George.
He would say some of the most fucked up.
Ridiculous over the top shit,
but the reason why I did it is because
that's like what shocks us shit out of
you and makes you laugh when you least
expect it.
And it was like,
well crafted in,
on top of that.
He made me laugh harder than anybody's
ever made me laugh in a club.
We were doing a pizzeria in Pennsylvania
and he said something.
It was,
it was barbarism and it made me,
it was because of the imagery.
It was such,
it was,
it was such poetry that he flew off the
top with that.
It was awful.
And uh,
I've ever told you this story and it was
like,
it won't hold,
like if I say it now,
it's not gonna be the greatest jokey,
but the beauty of it,
we were in a pizzeria.
It was an awful gig.
And um,
it was,
uh,
it was like,
we're like real pizzeria bench seats.
It stunk.
And uh,
there was a bar next to it and I'm
watching it.
It was just up there fucking struggling
and hitting it.
And in the middle of this dirty act,
the bookers girlfriend walks down the
aisle with her seven year old son,
which was so inappropriate.
And everybody looked at it,
just derails the show.
And Auto,
uh,
just said,
you know,
because everyone looked at the fucking,
the puppet addressed it and said,
oh,
isn't,
isn't that cute.
I'd like to grab him by the ankles and
smashes Scotland to a fucking sink.
And it was a caligula reference to the
end of Caligula.
And it made me the,
the,
the
speed at which he put those words
together.
And the,
the,
the violence attached to that.
Uh,
and the imagery of that,
I've never laughed harder than anything
anybody's ever said in a comedy club
because I knew what had just happened is
it was just,
I immediately saw the end of Caligula
where they grabbed the ankles and they
smash the fucking head into the steps.
And I'm like,
the genius to pull that out in this
moment and word it that quickly.
It just,
it was,
but it was beauty.
But it was a horrible.
And nobody laughed.
Of course they didn't affiliate
pizzeria.
Nobody understood how funny that was.
He had just said that and I hadn't seen
Caligula.
I might not have laughed as hard,
but the fact that I immediately saw what
he did with it,
I was just.
I wanted to hug them for that.
I'm like,
you brilliant,
brilliant guy.
He's a brilliant fuck man.
He's a very funny guy and his style of
comedy,
much like dyson style of comedy is
ridiculous over the top things.
They don't really mean like dice has a
some bit about about how a woman gets
pregnant and it's one of the most
hilarious,
ridiculous bits because it goes into
like this medical or how you can make a
gay kid like how fucking so fucking
ridiculous idiocy it's completed,
but it's hilarious and for people to say
that that's a homophobic joke,
know he doesn't believe he doesn't mean
a word.
He's saying,
do you understand that this is.
This is like an art piece that you're
watching.
This is just a ridiculous over the top
art piece,
and for you to say that it's not viewed
to say that I shouldn't be enjoying it,
well then we have to go with a fine
tooth comb over virtually all of pop
culture,
every song.
We have to find out what the true
meaning behind movies are,
what,
what's the implication on society?
Because it can't just be humor.
It's this.
It's a dumb way of looking at it
because,
you know,
it's a joke.
If it's a standup comedy show,
you know,
it's a fucking joke.
At least in that sense.
There's no excuse with a rap music with
a rap song.
Like,
no,
it's not a joke.
Maybe he's being serious with a movie.
Maybe they're trying to promote that
lifestyle.
Maybe that's real.
It's a standup comedy show.
The only reason why people are laughing
is because it's a joke.
Well,
people do know that,
but it's unfunny people attempting to
influence these people,
trying to influence what you say.
It's like the same mentality and I don't
mean individually like let's just say
the same mentality that would target
dice or that would say,
um,
you should get in trouble for a gay joke
are the exact same people who would
stand up and defend Maple Thorp,
that the same people who would defend
piss Christ and say that the national
endowment of the arts should have paid
for piss Christ because who tell people
what that is?
It's,
it's,
it's at the NDA and I think paid for it
was an artist who pissed into a jar and
you put a crucifix in it and he called
it piss Christ.
Now,
I don't think that that's particularly
clever,
but it doesn't offend me on any level.
And here's more inconsistency.
Is the same people clever.
Yeah.
I mean it was,
you know,
look,
I wouldn't mind if I wish I would have
thought of that.
I mean,
I just,
I couldn't fill the jar with my pis.
Would've been
like two weeks.
Yeah.
I really wasn't a big jar too.
It's very impressive.
Yeah,
it's a very,
it's a two kegger.
But,
uh,
the fact that he,
they,
they support that and they're the same
people who would have attacked Giuliani
for going after the fucking Brooklyn
Museum of art because that Guy Pin
African artists painted,
uh,
the Virgin Mary and Dung.
So they would call him a fascist for
that.
Um,
you're,
you don't understand the art.
If you attack Maple Thorp and you don't
understand art,
if you attack piss Christ.
However,
if you attack a common well,
that comic is insensitive and he's
saying something racially,
racially insensitive or,
or gender intensive.
And it shouldn't be.
It's inconsistency.
You can't fucking respect if you can't
acknowledge any of it with respect,
it's people have to,
you have to leave room for art.
And that sounds ridiculous when you're
talking about Dick Jokes or any kind of
jokes,
but you have to leave room for art
because that's what it is,
is just an art.
And if you don't appreciate that style
of art,
it's no different than you deciding to
go to a metallica show and not liking
the lyrics.
Right?
If you don't like it,
you don't have to like it.
There's jody Mitchell's planned down the
block,
go see that.
Go,
go,
go see sheryl crow or go see Dave
Matthews.
There's a lot of variety out there,
but at the end of the day,
it's something that someone creates and
when Otto says,
you know,
I'd like to pick him up by his ankles
and slammed his head into a sink and
you're laughing.
That means he delivered art to the
person who likes that art and I feel the
same way when I.
When I see,
look,
when I saw dykes or when I saw you and
Austin,
same feeling.
I enjoy ridiculous over the top humor.
It's my one of my favorite things to
watch.
So when someone comes along and says,
you can't do jokes about violence
against children because it's fucked up.
Yes you can.
You can.
Even if your kid killed it.
Well unfortunately for you,
this one hit home and it's not fun to
you,
but everybody else doesn't have a kid
that was killed by slamming their head
into a sink.
It becomes fun for them and it sucks,
but you can't just stop the art form
because it's going to hit you and that's
one of the things that came up in that
conversation with Lindy Lindy,
Lindy West,
one of the things that came up in the
conversation with her was that she was
talking about rape jokes and meanwhile
she had a photo on her twitter of Jeff
Goldbloom who was in death wish with a n
w who enacted a really horrific rape
scene at barbera grape signo.
Scary,
terrifying.
No joke.
There was no jokes involved.
There was no hee hee,
ha ha,
no double entendres,
and yet an actor doing that in that
piece of art somehow or another is
exonerated from the impact and this idea
that you should know that one third of
the audience.
I think the current thing they're
enjoying banding about.
When people talk about.
I shouldn't say they're enjoying,
I don't want to dismiss it,
but the people who really believe this
believe that one third of all women have
been either sexually assaulted or raped
and there's people that dispute that and
there's a lot of it is based on a
certain study from,
I believe it was 1987 and there was a
lot of questions that are very in that
study,
like they'd say if you ever had sex with
someone and then regretted it or do we
are coerced into having sex and things
along those lines.
They called all of those rates and so
then I think,
but I think their findings was like one
in five,
but now people are saying it's one and
three,
whatever the fuck it is.
The idea that you have to like not.
You have to censor yourself because of
the you can choose to.
You can choose to if that's your style
of comedy,
you can choose to,
but for you to get mad at someone who
doesn't choose to.
It's like,
Oh,
you're.
This is a slippery slope and I know
people don't think it's a slippery slope
because you think it's all just about
protecting people's feelings,
especially victim's feelings and I see
your point,
but at the end of the day we're going to
have to go over this whole motherfucker
with a fine tooth comb.
If you want to do that.
You can't just single out standup comedy
because it's coming from one person and
not a giant movie where a woman gets
assaulted and beaten or raped or
whatever.
I mean all of it has to be looked at,
but you have to look at the whole thing.
See,
I and I also feel like I give myself the
same credit I give the audience like I
really do,
and it's like we all say,
we want to just just treat people like
you want to be treated well.
I treat the audience with the same level
of intellectual respect that I want.
And I went and saw Joan rivers and it's
not.
It's the edgiest set I've ever seen a
comic do and I mean it's a few years ago
at the cutting room in New York.
She's doing nine slash 11 jokes,
ai mean fucking brutal,
and I was when I was,
I literally wanted to cry at the end of
it because I'm like,
that is what we should be doing.
It is taking everything horrible that we
experienced and I mean horrible and
making a room full of people laugh about
it and when we walked out of there,
my feelings about nine slash 11 had not
changed my feelings about rape,
my feelings about aids,
not one thing she said made me value
those real experiences,
less not one thing she said made me
devalue anything made me lose respect
for the horror of nine.
Nothing changed for me other than I was
able to temporarily laugh at something
that I knew was awful,
so why wouldn't I give my audience the
same credit for being able to come to
the conclusion I came to watching Joan
rivers well
to,
to take their argument.
It would be because you haven't been
raped,
you haven't been murdered.
He didn't lose loved ones in nine slash
11 and that what you should be doing by
omitting rape jokes is you should be
avoiding triggers.
You get ptsd triggers,
avoiding people freaking out and
thinking about the rape while they're at
a comedy show.
Just try and have a good time and so
their.
Their opinion is set up entirely to
protect the victims of these crimes.
It's not like a person like you has a
certain sensibility about nine slash 11.
Joan rivers defies that sensibility but
does it in a humorous way and you walk
away with the same opinions that you had
going in because that's not really what
you're dealing with.
You're dealing with is a victimization
crime,
a crime or someone's been dehumanized
and them being in the audience watching
you talk about that.
You should be more sensitive than that.
So that's.
There are very good argument and a lot
of ways.
My point back to them would.
I do understand
that,
but like I said,
whenever I talk about tiger woods,
his text messages,
I reveal my own.
I talk about my own.
I also talk about things that have
injured me,
talk about my own suicide attempts in my
own sexual proclivities like so.
I include will you,
do you use certain things horrible and
things that have affected me and things
that haven't.
I don't.
It's not like I exclude things and if
you break down here,
we're like that.
Like you said,
fine tooth comb.
Every single joke or 90 percent of the
jokes you do,
unless you're talking about balloons are
bouncing a ball,
have hurt somebody.
Well,
he's talking about,
oh my God,
was I drunk driving?
Oh my God.
That's children being killed by drunk
driving is not.
But if we get that literal with humor
than almost all jokes comics tell our
are going to be up for a,
a careful examination and I think matt
and Trey said it's either all or none of
it's okay.
I won't make pedophile jokes when Kevin
fucking bacon can't play them in the
woodsmen I'll,
I won't do gun jokes when fuck it.
Hollywood can't tell me how bad guns
are.
And then they make a movie called two
guns with which I have no objection to,
but then don't fucking preach to me
about guns.
Motherfuckers just,
you know,
I don't care what you do as an artist,
leave me alone as an artist.
I don't tell you what to do,
don't tell me what to do.
That's all it is.
No,
your point is dead on.
And it's a,
it's a very important point.
The,
uh,
the idea of censorship.
I can understand that people don't want
someone in the audience to be impacted
negatively about you making light of
something that's a horrific crime that
they've suffered from personally.
But that doesn't mean you should stop.
Okay?
And it doesn't mean that you're a dick
either.
What it means is you're saying something
that hits them personally and you know,
then maybe you shouldn't go see Jim
Norton.
And that sounds like a fucked up thing
to say.
But really that's,
that's the reality of the situation.
This is what you're doing is a style of
art.
People who don't want to be scared don't
go see the conjuring or the evil dead
because they don't.
Like I don't like horror movies.
How come nobody's trying to stop horror
movies?
People that don't like them don't go to
see them,
so the same way she'd be with certain
types of humor and what's.
When you break it down,
what's the worst that can happen if you
see something like,
am I going to talk about something that
they don't show on law and order
constantly?
Jesus,
the whole thing's a fucking rape murder
fest.
Everything people like it is a rape or a
murder or some kind of voyeurism and I
will acknowledge and honor people's a
porn to violence.
When does an accident in the southbound
lane and the traffic in my lane doesn't
slow down.
People slow down to look because they
want to see it.
They want to fucking see it on some
level,
but they don't admit they want to see
it.
And I hate their lack of admission.
Well,
there's a weird exclusion thing too.
If you're.
You're discussing rape and you're not
discussing murder.
You know,
if you have anything that involves a
rape in a tweet or something,
you're,
you're a piece of shit or you know,
you should have had a tour,
a trigger warning in there like this is
the attitude that a lot of people are
taking about this stuff,
but why does it have,
why doesn't anybody have the same issues
about murders?
You can talk about a murder,
you can talk about like,
no,
it's very rare that people get upset at
murder jokes or murder movies or
anything murder.
But there was a obama thing recently
where Obama said that,
uh,
he could have been trayvon Martin and I
said,
you know who else he could've been?
It could've been a little kid that got
killed by drones,
right?
No,
nobody.
Right.
That's A.
I mean,
it's not really a joke per se,
but it's,
it's kind of like blocking him,
mocking the idiocy of this.
But it's also bringing up murder.
It's bringing up people getting hit with
missiles now.
Bodies exploding.
Why is that image any less disturbing
than the image of rape?
Are they,
are they equally disturbing or they both
off the menu or why are we only going
with rape off the menu?
How come there's like zero push to take
murder off the menu?
Their argument with bb,
and again,
this is what they would say is because
rape,
murder victims were people.
Murder,
is that you're not taught to be silent
about murder.
You're taught to be silent about rape.
And there's a lot of rape victims who
are too scared to report the crime.
No one is scared to report a murder
lists mob thing,
right?
They're saying the perception of the
crime is different.
And uh,
there's such a shame with it where
there's not ashamed with murder.
There's not ashamed with these other
things.
And again,
I heard what she said and I listened to
it and I did get it,
but I won't.
I don't do a whole shitload of jokes on
rape victims anyway.
Um,
but if that's the case,
and it probably is the case then be for
castration of rape rapists or were fight
the fact that the recidivism rate is so
high in these fucking pigs because
they're being.
Let out of jail,
like fight that don't worry about with
dumb jokes,
contributing to a fucking rape culture
is nonsense and it is to say comedian
contributes to rape culture is simply
bullshit and it's simplistic thinking.
It's a way of saying I don't like what
you're saying and I don't want you to
say it,
but I can't come out with that,
so I have to find a higher reason.
Which makes it sound like you shouldn't
say it for this reason.
Well,
even the term rape culture,
you know,
someone in my message bird said,
do they have meetings?
They have a magazine.
Like is it really a culture?
Like what?
What are you talking about?
And by calling it that,
by defining it in those terms,
we're calling it rape culture.
You would you put quotes around that it
starts to be real and what I don't mean
that it's going to encourage people to
rape,
but I mean the idea that there's a
culture that supports rape is going to
be real.
It's going to be something that people
address as if it's real.
Regardless of whether or not it is,
is it real that people rape?
Absolutely,
but it isn't real that our culture
supports it.
Fuck no man,
of course that most people have moms.
Most people have sisters.
What we,
what we have a problem with in this
country is a lot of people are making
shitty human beings.
There's a lot of terrible fucking
parents are doing a shitty job and then
making shitty human beings and they're
also
raising these shitty human rings around
a bunch of other kids that were created
by shitty human beings and they don't
know what the fuck they're doing either
and no one's paying attention to their
kids.
Making a human being and raising a human
being is a massive undertaking and all
the people out there that are doing
their best.
I commend you and congratulate you.
All the parents out there that are
taking their kid to wrestling classes
and martial arts and their daughter to
dance classes or martial arts if she
wants to do it or anything.
Were you getting them involved in
activities D,
building discipline,
disciplining them,
developing their character.
Most people don't get that in this life,
right?
They don't get taught how to behave,
how to be a good human being,
the qualities and the values of
friendship and community that should be
bestowed upon children at a very early
age,
but for most of us,
we have to get the fuck out of the house
for.
We can even figure out that on our own
and we figured it out by friendships and
we figured it out by meeting people in
life and learning from them,
but we're doing a real shit job of
raising kids right out of the box and so
you come into life with a deficit and
that deficit manifests itself in a bunch
of Shitty fucking behavior.
Whether it's violence or whether it's
rape,
whether it's stealing,
whether it's,
whether it's plagiarism,
whether it's a,
whether it's taking advantage of of of
people in any way like what are you
doing?
Like why you doing that?
Why are you being such a shitty human
being?
And that's what is not emphasized enough
in our culture.
It's not about.
It's not just about making money.
It's not about getting ahead.
It's about cultivating good friendships
and a happy life,
and the only way you could do that is to
be nice.
Those motherfuckers that are ruthless
businessman,
those guys are all depressed.
They're all a bunch of fucking crazy
assholes.
Taken Ambien to go to sleep abused and
hookers and others.
Hey,
easy.
You know what I'm talking about?
Most of them had their throats cut like
honestly,
I think that.
I think that would change a little bit
if we dragged a few of those business
guys.
Not all of them,
but a few of them into the street and
killed him in the street.
I think that they would stop stealing
people's money.
Yeah.
There's a ton of pens.
I'm going to go push yourself.
Literally piss out of your pants.
I like to play a game.
The commercials?
Yeah.
These posts,
these little 15 minute radio.
Bladder.
Yeah.
We used to holding it for three hours
while drinking [inaudible] coconut
juice.
That's right.
CTO,
coach boundaries.
People say,
why are you drinking tea too?
I'll tell you why.
This is not a commercial.
They don't pay me anything,
but they send me coconut juice.
It's really good because it's from Thai
coconuts.
A lot of you have had coconut juice and
you're like,
oh my God,
this stuff tastes like ass.
You're right.
A lot of it tastes like ass Thai
coconuts,
a different animal.
It's short.
It's only like five feet tall and it
grows and it's like,
it's almost like a Bush two totally
different thing.
You know,
you think of those long,
tall ones.
The coconut to the top,
those aren't so good.
But then the Thai coconuts.
Oh,
that's sweet.
Oh yeah.
It's so great.
So like if you're hung over,
he are you when you wake up in the
morning and just like dehydrated.
Yeah.
I found out from my friend Ed when
Jujitsu came in and brought a case of
this shit and started handing it out to
people and I'll go,
what is this?
I never had had coconut juice.
It was gross,
but you know it's the best shit.
Yeah,
that's my thing where they chop off the
top and you have a little good to eat a
little of the skin,
scoop it out with a spoon.
That's the best.
If you can just hack the top off of a
delicious coconut and get a straw in
that bitch.
You know what's weird?
I,
I just found it,
you know,
I talked to,
I think we talked about this last
podcast and we talked briefly talked
about it today.
Uh,
I just found out like the blue
cigarettes,
the one that we always talk about with
that one dude in it,
you know that a sexy guy that's smoking
the fake cigarette,
Stephen Dorff,
that company blue is owned by the third
largest tobacco company.
Oh,
there you go.
And then the second largest just bought
a new company.
Uh,
and that's what their thing is now.
That's the way they're hit hooking the
kids on nicotine.
Now we have these fake cigarettes with
the cool blue lights.
I mean,
making all flavored soup tastes like
watermelon.
So now that's how they're getting there.
They're getting you again and then
they're making it better.
Now the kids are,
I know somebody that just got one of
these cigarettes and she's like,
I quit smoking.
I'm like,
oh,
that's great.
And I was like,
what do you got?
Well,
I got one of these electronic
cigarettes.
She sat there.
I watched her for probably like five
hours nonstop.
Just sucking on that thing like it was
air and those batteries.
It's pretty impressive.
Yeah,
those battery lasts pretty well.
What?
The rechargeable.
And they even have like little USB
plugs.
So they seem like a cool technology toy
box.
I've seen them.
They have like a metal box or a plastic
box,
so they charge it in.
Some of them.
Some of them,
like the ones that,
the one I have actually has this thing
he just hook up.
It has a USB cable and hook up to your,
uh,
the Jenny Mccarthy one that she's
pitching.
She's got the opposite of the Stephen
Dorff commercial.
What are we doing?
We're doing blue commercial.
She's fucking people.
I was,
I was the gathering of the Juggalos.
Did you do anything crazy happen when?
No,
it was,
it's funny.
Those guys off my cpa have been really
nice to me and I was hesitant to do that
gig because I hear it's like,
you know,
you're in the woods.
Oh yeah.
I have never watched this.
I can't watch myself.
What was this?
This was a TV show,
right show on fuse.
I was one of the first interviews
they've done confused.
What is it?
Where they just watched videos and kind
of mock them a second beavis and
butthead thing.
They smashed you in between them.
This is what uncomfortably close?
Yeah,
that's part of it to make.
Yeah.
I think I was one of the first
interviews I ever did.
Why did they want to touch you like that
while they're sitting there?
I don't know.
I think it was just for camera framing.
That was a shitty job of camera framing.
They just block us all in there.
Ridiculous.
That's like,
who's the,
who's the cousin?
I think that they just liked the
uncomfortability.
I like the fact that just really weird.
Yeah.
But together can I,
uh,
about the gathering of the Juggalos was
for the travel to it is an abomination,
but it was a really good gig and that
there's like 700 people in a tent.
I mean they were nice.
They were a little bit chatty,
but nowhere near what you'd expected an
outdoor festival gig.
Like I loved them and they will no
fucking nice.
Um,
one of my favorite porn girls was there
because she's a big fan of them and I
got the seizure favorite porn girl.
She's one of them.
I hadn't.
Is Pepper Kester you go deep to the
bottom
of the obscure Pornstar redhead,
right?
Yeah.
Big really big pussy lips.
I want to fucking,
I want to just,
I want to wear a pussy on my fucking
nose.
She was there.
She's a big fan of them yet.
So that was the highlight.
You get her back to hang out with
friends?
No,
we don't do anything.
She does.
Mostly I,
but I understand that she does mostly
lesbian porn.
I have no shot at fucking or um,
but,
but I still like,
I genuinely like her.
She's cool.
So.
Well there'll be no sexual and she
doesn't mind you beat off thinking about
her.
Oh no,
she's fine with it.
I'm trying,
I'm trying to work her up or I can walk
behind her and beat off.
Had she said she'd been listening to the
ONA about you talking about or has he
said anything about that?
People tweet her and she's happy that we
do,
but I've had dinner with her once and
again,
but I knew it was just going to be a
hang and she was actually really nice.
So that was cool.
I,
uh,
can I plug my specials?
I keep forgetting.
I'm going to go ahead.
I'm going to take a look.
Go ahead.
Playboy.
It's called American degenerate and it
premieres on epics on uh,
this month,
August the 23rd.
And uh,
yeah,
I'm looking all over.
What an unprofessional.
How to look at the camera.
Am I looking at the wrong one right
here.
There's,
there's the uh,
oh,
they're showing them talking and it's
August 23rd.
It's on Epix.
And if you don't have that because it's
epics hd.com
and you can get a free trial
subscription.
So whether or not you want to keep epics
is up to you,
but get the trial subscription online
and then you can watch it whenever you
want.
But I'm actually really happy with it.
Um,
is this something that you're going to
eventually like,
do you own this?
I do.
Only you can sell it.
I will,
yeah.
Cool.
But I want people to go and see it there
because epics gave me money to do it and
they artistically got out of my way.
There are amazing as far as for a
comedian,
the only thing you could do better than
with them as a network is just do it and
shoot it yourself and put it on your own
tv because they're very,
very good about leaving you alone,
which is a lot of comedian wants us to
be left the fuck alone from a network.
I know that Sam Roberts is in town right
now.
You guys are going to get to hook up and
do anything when he,
I think he's coming into tonight.
I probably won't see him.
I'm just too busy.
I'm doing a bunch of shit today and a
bunch of shit tomorrow.
And then I go home.
Uh,
and Wednesday I'm very,
very busy every day.
But I came out and I want it because
it'll be on Netflix and like eight
months.
But I legitimately wanted to do promo
for,
for this network because they've taken
good care of me and you don't get many
people like that anymore.
That give you the fucking freedom,
you know,
because every network person wants to
get their hands on your business and
they don't do that.
What for you and your special for epics?
Yeah,
they've been really good about it,
man.
And I'm the opening.
They were little heads.
I got an opening which I was really
happy.
Like I got someone special for my
opening and they were a little like,
uh,
but uh,
you know,
it wound up working out and they left me
alone and they were happy with it.
Who's on your opening?
I don't want to say I'll show.
I'll show it to you.
It's a secret.
Jimmy and I,
I should,
uh,
because last year I had ozzie do it and
ozzy and Sharon both tweeted like,
they really helped me out.
Oh that's awesome.
But this one,
Jonathan,
if you're listening,
could you email it to me?
I'll email it to joke because I have
not.
Uh,
no one has seen it,
like for people that have seen it,
I don't mean like that's big,
special secret.
Nobody gives a fuck.
But I mean,
I just haven't it.
I understand.
You don't want to let out the secret.
You've got a secret.
You create,
you crafted something.
Put together
a little secret.
I'm going to use it to promote the
special.
It's nice it epics is not fucking with
you and letting you do whatever you
want.
That's the only way to do it.
It's,
I,
I've done.
I tried before I ever did my first
comedy central special.
Why was on spike first?
Actually,
no,
it was on comedy central,
but before that there was a round I went
where they went over some of my material
and then be like,
no,
you can't say this now you can't say
that.
This is no good.
You can't even beat that out like this.
It just,
it got to be like,
all right,
we can't do this.
It's too frustrating to have to have to
have all that stuff.
Uh,
they,
they didn't have any content issue like
live.
As long as you're not slandering
somebody or liable,
whichever is the spoken word,
like you know,
you got to be careful.
You can't walk up and just say things
that are going to get you sued.
That's the only thing they care.
Like they were like fine with it.
They were very hands off and that's
beautiful.
It's.
Yeah,
it was refreshing.
Well,
you know what it is Jimmy.
I think that this,
this the same thing that we were talking
about how there's a broad spectrum of
art that people like,
whether it's music or movies or
whatever.
There's also a broad spectrum of of
content distribution methods and the one
that we've all been stuck with.
It was television,
15 minutes commercial,
another 15 minutes commercial.
All these fucking commercials and all
these breaks and all this editing and
all this censorship and all this shit
they're trying to sell in between and
Toyota cars and tide detergent and all
this shit that they're doing it other
than the actual performance itself.
Then all of a sudden the internet comes
along and then like Louis,
c,
k,
did you release it all?
You sell it for five bucks,
you watched the whole thing,
it's an entirety,
and then you go,
well,
why would I ever,
why would I ever fucking do it any other
way?
Why would I try to listen to a bunch of
other people try to shape it and then
put sandwich commercials in it and then
sensor it.
It's like it's such a shitty way of
distributing content.
Yeah,
and if became can't,
you're right.
The only way we knew was that it's all
we ever had.
Now there's a new way and Louis changed
a lot of things because the networks
realize that they have a certain amount
of power still,
but that is slipping and slipping.
I don't think.
I think you could do an online special
if you wanted to identity.
Oh,
you did?
Okay.
So my last one was totally online.
I did it on,
I paid for it,
did it online and then sold it to comedy
central comedy central now and I'm going
to do another one and I'm going to do it
the same way and it's like Louis said,
a perfect bar too,
so nobody can get greedy.
You know,
because you know,
Louise,
like top shelf a plus standup comic,
one of the greatest step,
you know,
of our generation without a doubt,
like between him and rock and Chappelle
was like four or five people that have
the greatest of our generation.
So if he puts up a $5 special,
that's what it costs now everybody's
going to do five bucks now because if
somebody stepped up first and try to do
20 and then if it,
you know,
it would have been one of those things
like kind of what do I price it at?
He made it a super reasonable.
It wasn't just that he was the pioneer
and doing the first one like this,
but also that he set the bar as far as
like the,
uh,
the,
the expense.
He said it really reasonably.
Yeah.
And there's
very smart,
very smart to do that.
Like that.
It's good.
And it's also when you cut out all the
other bullshit,
like as far as like,
he cut out all the other bullshit as far
as like networks and commercials and
putting them on,
you know,
the uh,
the amount of production money that has
to be paid off by commercials and all
that jazz.
When we take all that out of the
equation,
it's like pretty easy to get your money
back,
you know,
you have to sell that much to get your
money back and then it becomes
profitable.
Well,
unless you're dealing with one of these
fucking networks or production companies
that want to sneak in a 30 percent a
distribution fee on top of everything,
they fucked so many guys doing that.
Well.
Yeah.
Like you get some back end money but
they don't tell you that the 30 percent
distribution fee,
which is a vague,
you're paying a vague comes off.
So it's like,
well we made $100 but no,
we only made 70 because it's 30 percent
distribution becomes other.
And like,
what's it for?
Well it's just the distribution of it.
It's,
it's a nonexistent fucking thing.
So you know,
it's nice to be on my own with this one
and I own it and epics is leasing it and
they were amazing about well you're,
you're on serious and you guys are on
five days a week or some time Monday
through Friday,
Monday through Friday.
Now.
Do you ever think about doing something
on your own?
Do you see like in the time that you're
on,
like you guys were one of the first on
Sirius satellite radio and you know,
in my opinion like that move that where
we got shifted over to Sirius Satellite
Radio that changed a lot of like
people's ideas of how to do a radio show
because between you guys and Stern,
all of a sudden we heard swearing on a
regular basis on a radio show and it
became brewer brewer show,
brewer unleashed.
You got to hear like people just hanging
out.
And then I think that is what gave birth
to a lot of podcasts.
But you don't do a podcast.
No lie.
You know what it is?
I get,
I get 20 hours a week with those guys
and we replay all day.
I have five nights a week on Ozzy's
boneyard.
I hearst,
I hosted music show and I do my own
advice show once a week on Wednesdays
for an hour a week.
You do bone yards?
Yeah,
but it's only again,
you know,
you pre tape it,
but yeah,
I mean my voice is heard five nights a
week on butter and get the one hour
advice.
Shall I love?
Unwise.
That's actually some of the most fun.
Thank you man.
I love doing that.
So.
But my voice is heard a lot and I'm
freed up to do my standup,
which is what I want to do and I have
two shows that I want to get on the air.
That's my new obsession.
So one talk show and I have one scripted
show which I actually think is good and
I'm ultra critical.
My Shit and I always think it stinks but
like I'm actually happy with this so
hopefully I'll be able to get it sold or
do it online.
I'm just not big enough to do it online
yet.
I hope you never leave Ona,
but if you ever did leave on a,
you would have a gigantic fucking
podcast.
I don't know.
I feel like I wouldn't and I mean maybe
I would,
but I feel like,
uh,
I would be like,
Eh,
I'll be afraid to do that.
Man.
I love interviewing people that are
like,
I love doing it,
but I'm said East Coast podcast man,
they just don't trust podcast on the
east coast.
The only one I got spoiled with radio
because I'm so used to doing it that
way,
that,
uh,
to do it on my own.
I love your set up here.
You have a bigger studio that we do and
I love the way you've got to set up and
it's a great hang and it's well done.
Yeah.
Well,
this place I just had realized that
somewhere along the line I was
eventually going to have to do
something.
So I found this office space and just
over the course of a few months put it
together,
but it's really only become functional
over the last few months because for the
longest time we had a terrible Internet
connection.
It's a pain the Deq to build something.
Sure,
sure.
We had to get a fat pipe put in here,
so it's like 100 megabytes up and down.
It's a tremendous Internet connection,
so now we can stream and like easy with
no hiccups,
download things at ridiculous speeds
before we were like crippled with a
shitty DSL connection.
There's a lot of things that go into
building.
One of these things are hiring people to
build these things,
but it's cool to do because it's cool to
like make it your way.
Like,
I want a brick behind me.
Okay,
let's make it bricks.
I want a werewolf in the lobby.
Okay.
Right.
Well,
you know,
I want to.
Oh,
oak wall or Oak table that's made out of
100 year old reprocessed farm wood or
reclaimed barn wood.
So you can do shit like that because
it's yours.
Yeah.
Because you don't have to go through a
bunch of producers like,
well we want is the.
You see this thing behind me.
This goofy fucking fell in love that is
created by producers.
I want one of these things on the wall,
these black things that look like a
swastika.
They were claiming that people are
claiming that they're supposed to go.
I don't mind it though.
You know what?
It doesn't hurt the room at all.
I think the whole setup here is great
man.
And uh,
I will be too nervous to do my own
podcast.
Oh,
you're so crazy.
You'd be awesome at it.
And I dunno,
I,
I bore myself a lot.
Like I hate listening to myself unless
I'm doing uncle Paul then it doesn't
sound like me at all and I can listen to
it.
Well that is the problem with doing like
a lot of hours,
right?
You do a lot of hours on the radio and
after awhile you're like,
God damn it.
I don't have.
I think that sometimes we do three in a
week.
We do three,
three hour shows in a week I'll be like,
yeah,
we have,
but after like three,
like three is where I feel like I don't
want to hear me anymore,
you know,
I'm tired of me.
So you must be tired of me to know.
It's,
yeah,
it's 20 hours a week we do and uh,
you know,
again,
it's draining sometimes,
but it's also fun,
but it's also developed your
conversation skills and that's one of
the reasons why I really enjoy you like
in that a lindy west thing.
It was,
it was a fascinating debate.
You were the perfect person for that
because you're so succinct with your
words.
You're so used to being involved in
disagreements with people that you were,
you know,
how to keep things civil no matter what.
Like one of my favorite disagreements
with you was the Jesse Ventura one.
Jesse Ventura got all dickie with you
and he,
he tried to get like,
he tried to get abusive,
he tried to get like put his hand on
you.
He tried to bully you a little bit,
a little bit and you called him out on
it and it was,
it was really interesting.
Yeah,
it's weird.
Like I'm much more likely,
like you said,
you don't like to see weak people.
I don't like it either.
Like,
I'm much more likely to argue with a guy
who could throw me through a wall and
it's not a little man complex.
It's just,
I don't like when Paris Hilton was in,
she was not a good guest.
She's a Vapid jazz bagging.
Hated her,
but she wasn't being vicious eyesight.
It's
just too easy to attack her.
Right,
right.
She gives a fuck if I do Jesse then
sure.
I did not want to have this interaction
with.
I would have preferred it to be civil.
But uh,
the video does not tell the whole story.
The audio tells the whole story.
But the video because opiates,
so ocd and nuts,
he didn't take all of the taped like
when it started to get heated.
But Jessie was more aggressive with me
and uh,
you know,
when he patted me on the way out,
I knew he wasn't trying to hurt me.
But again,
the way for me to equal him was to pat
him and he was fucking sick.
Why you want to go back that far with
the Kennedy?
We can't go back to Vietnam.
You said to me were with those guys.
We're not going to send,
we send our guys love to war without
giving a shit,
and I'm telling you that's not true.
I agree with you.
When did you go to war?
I've never been in the industry.
You don't know,
but I say pull them out of everything
because I've never been in the military.
When we are attacked by a nation,
we should not be proven first.
I feel we proved that.
You feel we did.
You also feel that fucking Bush was
behind nine slash 11,
so we're always going to district very
go put fucking words in my mouth.
You feel that the US government was
behind it.
Who Do you think you are covering it
all?
You have not been told the truth.
So you feel like,
well,
okay,
wait a minute.
All right,
if you'll calm down the moment you're
yelling,
you're the governor talking your
language,
so you're wondering how you shouldn't
bring it down to my level.
Bring me up to yours.
I saw that you said about not going to
let me talk.
I'm out the door talking the whole time.
All you do is yell over people and you
don't want to address point by point.
You Act like we say,
send our boys to fuck them.
We've never said that.
I agree with you.
I want to pull them out of Germany.
I want to pull them everywhere.
The US military should never be dying
for other countries.
I don't care.
I don't care if Kim's job,
you'll take this out.
That's not my business.
I just think that if we're attacked,
we have the right to want our military
to respond,
so that's not some warmonger saying,
fuck the voice.
Send them over.
That's what I walked in and he sits and
looks at Jimmy.
Why Awkward?
That was a fair point.
I just made you a raw when you said
that.
I don't know.
I didn't listen to over,
you know,
yelling at me because I'm not talking.
I'm not yelling at you.
I'm just telling you back to your point.
You accused us of something.
So let's say that you guys are just full
of Shit.
Interesting
guy,
Jimmy,
because you're a liberal and a lot of
ways,
but you're also conservative in a lot of
ways.
What is that?
Oh,
thank you John.
Okay.
You're,
you're,
uh,
you're very conservative and right wing
and a lot of ways.
Certainly you're also very liberal.
Like,
do you still like to hear what you're
saying in this and you still stand by
what you're saying about pulling our
government,
our military out of everywhere.
Absolutely.
You think fuck the rest of the world.
Fuck Egypt.
I'm sick of given them money.
When people hear,
don't eat.
Yeah.
I'm tired of US fucking telling
everybody else how to live their lives
and we don't do it.
We tell,
we tell,
we tell people don't do this,
don't do that.
And meanwhile,
if two guys want to get married,
they can't.
If we were not full of shit and we were
consistent,
I'd be fine with it.
Just don't.
I just think that the rest of the world,
fuck them.
But do you really believe that we were
attacked by country?
Um,
I believe about sending troops into
other.
I'm in Afghanistan,
not Iraq.
What did you think?
We were attacked by Afghanistan,
no,
but what I meant by that,
and this was more to this,
was the fact that the Taliban held bin
Ladin and shielded Bin Ladin and refused
to give him to us was what I felt
happened and I felt that they were,
they were complicit in allowing him to
operate there.
So while the whole country didn't attack
us,
I feel have they just given us bin
Ladin,
we never would've attacked Afghanistan.
You're a smart
guy and you know that the line that you
get from the media,
the press releases or what have you are,
you know,
it's garbage.
So why would you think that they really
were shielding Osama bin Ladin in
Afghanistan when you know what you know
about Jessica Lynch,
where they lied about Jessica Lynch
being rescue.
She was kidnapped and meanwhile she's
just in a hospital in,
in Iraq,
and they didn't even fire a bullet when
they got her out of there and she
actually was pretty vocal about it.
And in that received death threats and
was threatened by numerous people that
she was called a trader because she
didn't go along with the company line.
And then of course,
you know the Pat Tillman story,
you know the difference between his
brothers version of the events and his
brothers version of how his son or his
brother,
Pat Tillman felt about being in the war
once he was there.
So different from what,
what the government was saying,
their press releases.
And then when we found out that it was
actually friendly fire that killed him,
he was actually killed by American
troops.
The whole thing becomes incredibly
complex and really fucked up.
And you're realizing that someone's
lying to you and they're painting a bad
picture.
So why would you assume that they're
telling you the truth about Osama bin
Ladin being hit by the Taliban in
Afghanistan?
In that case?
I believed it.
They have at the time you did.
And I still probably.
I still think the Taliban knew he was
there and was happy he was there.
No,
I don't blame them.
That's their religious fanatics.
He's a religious guy.
I get it.
Have
you ever talked to them?
Sorry to interrupt you,
but have you ever talked to special
forces guys?
I know you talked to a lot of those
guys,
like you have them on your podcast like
you had that we had.
We had Chris Kyle,
the guy who was killed.
Yeah.
Will you tie ever talked to them about
Osama bin Laden?
Um,
yeah,
we have a lot of them.
Don't think that that guy wasn't even
alive.
They think he had been dead a long time
ago,
that they just decided to use it as a
good time to say they got them.
And that Benazir Bhutto that will,
that was killed in a,
um,
an explosion.
Remember that?
No.
Is that her name?
Was she the one who was shot,
killed?
Who was the woman that was killed?
She was president or she was running for
president.
I
wish I knew.
I'm such a fucking idiot when it comes
to foreign policy.
Killed.
Anyway,
she said,
whoever this woman was,
she said that,
uh,
yeah,
that's it.
Benazir Bhutto.
She was killed in 2007.
She said that she went to his funeral,
I mean,
she was a prime minister of Pakistan,
two consecutive term nonconsecutive
terms.
Which shot though,
is that?
Or was it?
That was the bar and she.
She said,
I mean,
this is not a woman that has any reason
to lie.
She said she went to his fucking
funeral.
The,
maybe it was one of those fake funerals,
like,
hey,
maybe,
or just as fucking put out.
Maybe they knew that bitch would tell.
So let's bring it to a fake funeral.
She'll talk some shit.
We made a fake Osama bin Ladin and then
he can hide in Pakistan.
That's possible too.
It didn't really help Obama.
I mean,
like I firmly believe.
I do think that he was there.
Um,
and I do think that they just caught
them the way they said.
I don't believe everything the
government tells me at all,
but in this particular case it makes
sense to me and I,
it's not that difficult to stretch them
to make that.
He was holed up there and they finally
got it.
But it took 10 fucking years.
Like,
I don't see the government being patient
enough or anybody not wanting to grab,
like Bush was getting slaughtered in
the,
in the polls.
There's no way anybody would like a rip
on the Republican side would have
allowed that to continue or you know
what I mean,
whether they could have grabbed the
glory for it as opposed to a under
Obama's watch.
So do I believe that the Taliban was.
If it was the French government,
I would not have believed they were
hiding him.
Even Saddam Hussein,
I probably wouldn't have believed and I
was at originally for the Iraq war and
then I'm against it.
I shouldn't have been for.
Um,
but with Afghanistan I feel they were
much more religious fanatics and you see
the way the Taliban are and I do think
that they were protecting him and they
were okay with him being there.
So that was why I was okay with us
lashing out at them.
Um,
Iraq was a mistake and I wish we hadn't
gone there because I think that most of
the rack people don't give a fuck about
us and I don't think our American lives
should be shed over that shit.
Like I believe in pulling,
get them out of Germany to Wiley and
fucking Germany.
It's a waste of money.
Yeah.
But do you think that uh,
we're really in Iraq for the Iraqi
people?
No,
no,
of course not.
We're in Iraq to make some money.
They're there to control oil then we
should say most likely.
Right.
You can't say that because nobody's
going to agree to go to war then.
I mean,
that's been the strategy from the
beginning of time.
That's what Eisenhower warned people
about when he was leaving office.
That's what people have always said.
I mean,
did you ever read that?
Um,
uh,
Smedley Butler thing he wrote,
he was a general in 1935.
He wrote both.
No,
I haven't.
So what's kind of a famous piece?
It's called war is a racket and he wrote
this whole thing about his entire career
in the military being a racket.
And it was all about really about money,
about bankers and about oil companies
and about all these different things
where he was really,
he thought he was doing one thing,
but he's really just protecting the
interests of these gigantic
institutions.
And when you read it,
it's really hard to read because it's
hard to wrap your head around the fact
that this was 1930 something and it's
the same now.
It's the same way now,
almost 100 years later,
18 years later.
And it's basically the same,
you know,
I agree with a lot more of that than I
would have five or six years ago.
What's changed?
Just just,
just,
uh,
you know,
guys like Bernie madoff and all of
these.
It just growing up a little bit more or
looking at things differently or reading
more about,
you know,
just whatever,
whatever changes in opinion.
And over time I've never afraid of
looking back and going,
oh,
I should have thought another way on
that.
I don't have.
That's why I don't.
Again,
I don't try to convince the audience
that I'm right.
I'm just honest about my opinion.
500.
Well,
you're brave with your opinions too,
which is important.
You know,
you,
if you really believe it,
you have a reason for believing it and
you're willing to talk about it,
you know,
I think that's a,
that's a,
that's a rare thing.
People don't want to do that.
They don't want to take chances with
controversial subjects.
It's a very controversial subject to
defend war or even criticize war.
It's controversial.
It's like,
you know,
becomes a,
it becomes a topic of heated discussion
always.
I feel like with the Afghan government,
again,
if,
if I found out that they weren't
shielded,
been loud,
and I say,
Oh God,
I was wrong about that.
To really find out about the Afghan
government is that we pay the brother of
cars by the CIA.
He's a drug dealer.
The CIA has been paying him for almost a
fucking decade or something crazy like
that.
Have you interviewed sod any know who's
a buddy of Jonathan's?
Although he knows everything about.
He's from Afghanistan.
Oh yeah.
What does he do?
He runs moby.
He's,
uh,
he's like the Rupert Murdoch of
Afghanistan.
What's moby?
Uh,
it's,
it's a media company,
he's a TV station there,
a sadness in Afghanistan.
He knows everything about it and he
would,
he could tell you about the Taliban
because he's communicated with them,
he knows and he's a guy you would love,
love to have on the show.
He's a great guest.
That sounds awesome.
Really Bright Guy.
He would be able to answer that question
a very well and he would be very
accurate and whatever he said because he
knows those guys.
You know what my favorite story about
Afghanistan is how they talk the Taliban
to giving up the position or they how
they talk,
the war lords,
the local guys into giving up the
position for the Taliban.
I Agora,
yes.
Given Viagara Viagra like guns,
I don't need guns.
Plus I have 20 was then I cannot even
get it up and then they're like,
oh,
okay,
we got you.
All the sudden he's old dudes are just
naked.
The perpetual hard ons.
This running these heroines that they
have up there and what would it be?
Barbaric way of living life.
They have mean they,
they have these,
these with a lot of people don't realize
about Afghanistan is if you watch
documentaries on it or talk to people
that have been there.
It really is like it's frozen in time.
Like there's people that are warlords
and they control segments of the,
of the land and then there are bordered
by other warlords and these guys have
like 20 wives and it's.
It's a weird wacky sort of a way of
life.
Fifteenth Century.
It feels century.
I don't relate to it at all and again,
I don't think we should be over there
interacting.
I just,
not that we should never have
interaction with the countries,
but the fact that we try to throw our
ideas into other people's business like
I don't care what North Korea does.
It's nothing to do with me.
I'm all that money.
We waste on fucking other countries
should be spent on American citizens and
if we want obamacare,
finally,
let's take care of everybody.
Take that billion you're given to Egypt
and then fucking give it back to the
American people.
Like give people here who have their
fucking pensions taken away,
uh,
you know,
give them that billion dollars like
there's,
so we waste so much money and I think
that the,
like you said,
the asterisk with that should be,
if anybody attacks us physically,
our response should be embarrassingly
bad.
Linkedin,
she'd be embarrassingly strong and,
and,
and devastating.
So I think that should be the only.
That should be the thing that you do
what you want,
but if you come into our yard,
um,
we will,
uh,
we will blast you out of existence.
Childish,
by the way,
I'm sure.
Well,
I'm childish in a lot of ways to it,
but as a standup comedian,
I think it's ridiculous for me to try to
even attempt to understand what it must
be locked,
running foreign policy just to say that.
Sure,
sure,
sure.
But if you,
if you look at the entirety of the
situation,
you would see that they would,
I would think that there's probably a
benefit and giving a lot of people money
because they make you and you're
indebted to you.
Those people are indebted to you.
And then you can kind of do things.
Sure,
you can put bases over there,
you can extract resources,
you could do all this shit.
The United States does.
Sure.
And we can't do all that if we don't
give the money and if we don't give them
money.
And then they all start fucking forming
their own organizations,
then it's not one world power anymore.
Like it is now.
Like the reason why one world power
works is because we put the whole world
into sort of a perpetual welfare state
where the whole world relies on the
United States either for military
support or from financial support or
something.
And by doing that you kind of,
it,
it's,
it's a terrible way of looking at it.
But the reality is when you have these
countries that are indebted to you,
those countries kind of,
Oh you,
you can get them to do shit and stay
calm and they don't try to take over the
world.
You know,
they oh fuck,
load of money.
You have military bases there and you
keep things on that level.
And when,
when you tell people how many bases the
United States has in other countries,
most people have no idea.
There's more than a hundred different
countries in the world that have United
States military presence.
Like when you hear about that,
you'll go,
wait a minute,
what we,
this is what I love about us.
And again,
I love America.
I really do.
And I do think we're a great country.
I mean they talk about American
exceptionalism and believe a lot of it.
And some
of it I think is a bit overblown.
But,
uh,
I have patriotism and pride and you
know,
this is not about me.
Oh Fuck America at all.
I just hate the hip because the same
mentality that got do as I say,
not as I do,
Shit trickles down into our daily lives
and eventually effects us as comics and
performers because the people feel
comfortable being self righteous are
duplicitous and it makes me fucking
crazy.
But like we're bellyaching about
snowden.
The,
what the fuck do we think the Soviets
are going to do?
We have had our door open to Soviet
defectors forever and we cry that
they're keeping him.
Of course they should keep him.
I don't blame the Soviets for not giving
him back.
We're going to huff and puff when all
we've done is say,
hey,
if you're a defect or come on over,
we'll take care of you and we should do
that.
Not only that,
do you know what the reason,
like the critical boiling
point was when they decided to accept
his,
uh,
his acceptance for his,
um,
application for asylum.
Thank you.
Can Stumble through that quick enough.
The United States was criticizing Russia
for trying to silence political dissent.
There.
There were literally had the balls to
criticize Russia for silencing political
dissent.
While the biggest whistleblower in the
history of our country is sitting in
their airport and they were like,
really?
Like,
are you guys that fucking deft?
Are you that fucking dumb?
It's not death.
It's Daft,
right?
We are that whatever the word is,
Yeah.
You guys that arrogant that you think
that you can criticize us while we're
holding the guy that fucking released
all those documents that prove that you
guys are lying twats yeah.
And then the government,
I mean he went on Obama,
went on the tonight show with Jay Leno
and was lying about it.
Wasn't,
wasn't telling the truth about releasing
the.
First of all,
he was saying that people are not being
spied on,
but that's not true.
People are being spied on and they're
telling the dea to there showing them
how to fake a investigation so that they
don't show that they got the records
from the NSA there showing them how to
retroactively piece together an
investigation investigation.
So they say,
well,
we are,
we arrived at our results this way.
If you already know someones guilty
because you have the NSA,
uh,
paperwork on them,
email,
phone calls,
what have you,
all you have to do is zoom in on this
guy and then you could find the evidence
and find a reason to,
to investigate him.
Cause you know,
he's guilty already.
You can just piece it together easily
and again on where are they doing that
to American citizens for normal
interactions or was it really for people
who were using the a loophole of being
here and communicating so we couldn't
get into like we're the.
It's almost like somebody once said
after 9:11
this the constitution is on a suicide
pact.
Like were they attempting to.
And I,
I don't know the answer to it.
Were they attempting to use like a
America's law is kind of against it.
Like,
well,
I was American consistency
using the dea.
The Dea was investigating citizens for
selling drugs.
Always draw the.
Okay,
I'll do as you were saying that.
Yeah.
As far as I know,
it's American citizens and believe so I
have to go to the store.
I don't want that.
I don't want this to that.
Right.
I don't want to use not just that.
The real problem with is not just the
fact they're catching people doing
things like,
I'm all for you.
Removing meth labs.
Don't get me wrong.
The problem is you're also asking
investigators to fake an investigation,
and when you do that,
you're asking public servants to lie and
you're asking people that are in a very
noble position,
the position of law enforcement,
you're actually asking them to behave
unethically.
You know what the fucking laws are,
and you know if you catch someone doing
something and you don't want to reveal
the message in what you caught them,
so you think it's okay to lie.
Well that's a slippery goddamn slowly
that gets real slippery.
You're thinking an investigation.
What else are you fake and what I mean?
That opens the door to you faking
evidence that opens the door to you.
Faking a lot of shit if you think that a
person is is,
is guilty if you can't prove it,
and that's always been what said.
That's how Oj got off.
That's a whole mark furhman thing that
he might have.
People said,
hey man,
you might be fucking planting evidence.
Sure,
there's a lot of.
That shit is real.
We see it all the time.
There's a million videos on youtube of
cops that got busted planting things or
stories online.
People get busted.
So that sort of mentality is extremely
dangerous and that's why I'm against it
and that makes sense.
And uh,
and you know,
I'm against it for is basically a
perverse reason.
It is just simply a dislike of this nosy
con culture we have become and it makes
me crazy.
So I,
I like to see people getting it.
Like I like to see people going,
oh,
when it's me,
it's different.
And I,
and again,
someone could sit down and go,
well,
don't do it.
Of course I understand the difference
between the government doing it and us
looking at tiger,
of course I get that.
Well,
you know,
sociologists have an interesting take on
what's going on and it's as far as our
attraction to gossip,
gossip magazines and tmz type things and
celebrity gossip.
And what they're saying is that we're in
a weird point in time where we have the
largest populations,
big giant populations,
but we don't know each other anymore.
You mean you live in New York City,
you live in an apartment building,
right?
How many people live in your apartment
building?
40 five stories.
A lot.
40 five stories of people.
How many is that?
7,000.
500.
A thousand maybe.
I just don't know how some people will
think about that.
Think about what a big neighborhood that
is.
That's a massive neighborhood.
How many people in that fucking building
do you know?
Literally my neighbor and a couple of
maybe two.
Yeah,
it's craziness.
So they're saying that we're missing a
need for a community and we're missing.
There's like a draw of like busy body
about each other like finding what the
cultural parameters and boundaries are
and establishing them by talking about
shit.
And normally there would be like a
village and everybody in the village,
it'd be like 50 a hundred people.
Whatever the fuck it is.
And we would all kind of know each
other's business and figure out what's
cool and what's not cool.
Sure.
But when you're in this weird situation
where you don't even know the people
around you and then you're watching,
keeping up with the Kardashians,
that fills the void
where community should be.
That's why people are so God damn
attracted to quote unquote reality shows
as opposed to scripted shows because
they know when someone's being a
Dickhead,
there's no script to just be in a decade
and you're like,
oh that bitch,
I can't believe she said that to him and
they're really drawn into it because
they're lacking like a real community
and a real established like group of
people that you interact with on a
regular basis all the time and you in
your village and Plus Network tv did it
to themselves by emasculating comedies
and language and making everything so
soft and wrapped up and palatable that
it be that reality now stands out so
much more.
Part of that is a lot of extra what
you're saying and some of it is because
of the writing on regular television is
so soft and that's again,
that's not.
The writers are probably very good,
but it's just such fucking predictable.
Dereck,
all of it is such shit.
There's a lot of shit.
A lot of comms,
especially that's the worst.
There's no honest language.
There's no honest interactions.
Uh,
everything is presented in a way that
you know,
is going to be presented.
Have you seen the ads for the new
jackass movie?
Bad grandpa?
No.
Have you seen him?
Holy Shit.
Is it funny?
Oh really?
I went to see elise him last night and
they had this uh,
and for this jackass film and it's a,
it's a film they did were they made up
these scenarios and did all these little
stunts,
but they did them in front of real
people.
The people had no idea why it was going
on.
I mean it is fucking funny,
like laugh out loud.
Funny because you don't realize it as
you're watching it.
I was like,
is this an act like what is this?
You're getting tired.
They won't know how it looks most of the
time.
Anyway.
What
these are real people
gap
did is they had some scripted shit,
right?
And then the interacting with real
people.
That's funny about,
nope,
that's a great idea.
But Watch,
watch some of the shit that goes on.
God.
No.
Oh,
that's hilarious.
Good.
Take that child.
I'm sorry.
You're very pretty when you're mad.
Thank you for being here today.
I'll just call you when it has some fun.
No,
pretty little girl.
Got It.
Is that weird?
We just never seen it.
So it's different.
I don't want to tell people who are
listening to this,
what's happening because I could
probably get in trouble for describing
it.
Look at the graph.
Made it rain.
It's fucking funny.
I don't want to say anything.
Watch it on Youtube.
Why Watch the that?
That's awesome.
I didn't know about,
but what they did was instead of making
just another.
Am I on?
Yeah.
What they did was instead of making
another goofy comedy,
they made a hilarious thing where they
did it in front of people and the people
had no idea.
So it is like a movie.
You do have like a boar at sort of a
situation where they use real people as
they're filling them.
So great.
They're going to have to do shit like
that.
Yeah.
You did the same tired premises over and
over again,
like I haven't been to a comedy and
quite awhile it's been awhile since I
saw like an actual,
like sit,
you know,
one of those movies,
date movies or whatever.
I don't,
I,
I don't care.
I know what's going to happen.
You're both going to get together in the
end and everything's going to be funny
and Yay,
ha ha.
I'm tired of it.
And everybody's tired of it.
That's why something like this comes
along and it's just like,
Holy Shit.
It feels different.
What a great idea.
It hits you,
it catches you off guard the way comedy
is supposed to.
Where the film is supposed to.
It feels like,
oh,
this is fresh.
Did you,
what did you see?
Boron?
Um,
I never saw it.
I saw parts of it.
I'll tell you how dare you.
Did see a lot of it.
I didn't love it.
I'll tell you why.
I'll tell you why,
because I love the allergy show so much.
I didn't like the parts of it were
scripted.
Um,
I liked the g,
the allergy show where I believe it was
all real people and I didn't like the
fact that a lot of it was scripted in
Bora.
I didn't,
I didn't think it stunk,
it just,
I didn't really do much for me,
but they kind of had to do that.
Yeah,
it was a,
there were some very funny moments where
it brings the bag of shit down.
Like there's a lot of stuff that really
made me laugh.
Yeah.
No,
it was amazing man.
Uh,
I,
I love that kind of comedy more than
anything.
His show,
the leg show,
there's a lot of people today don't even
know that.
I wonder if he's going into hiding so
that he can do it again,
you know,
because it's really almost like that
show will never be erased from the.
I mean,
there's no way in this day and age you
could sneak that pass.
The publicist,
he needs another.
He needs another character.
No,
the character that no one has seen
before,
but it would not just have to be another
character.
You'd almost have to be another person
because it's too.
It's too the Internet.
It's too goddamn.
It's too much information about.
Will you shoot them,
shoot them all first.
You shoot them all and then you show
them.
You don't shoot them week to week.
You can definitely do that.
Yeah.
You'd have to do like one season,
right?
I know a lot.
TV production.
Consider
I can't get shit on the air.
It's amazing.
Fucking pontificating waiver and Lucky
Louie.
Once again,
somebody else does something and I just
come along for the ride.
Fucking I'll be riding shotgun.
My name should be your,
uh,
your thing that you're doing at
scripted.
Is this something that you created
yourself?
Yes.
And it's a sitcom or Wednesday.
It's like a single camera comedy about
me being a comic and a sex addict and I
think it's,
I think it's funny and uh,
you know,
I was like nine episodes written.
Who are you going to bring it to?
Um,
I've brought it to a few different
networks and they liked it,
but the problem was that Louise,
a comedian,
they were like,
well,
we don't want it.
You could lose,
which I get,
so I changed it to being a radio show
host,
which I actually like a lot better.
Um,
and I've just been kind of frazzled with
it.
I just haven't done anything with it.
I'm so stupid.
What do you mean?
What's wrong with you?
I just,
I,
you know,
I don't get this stuff done.
Like I should get it done.
I have a manager,
I have a personal appearance agent,
but I don't have an agent and uh,
we get as much done as we can.
Why don't you have an agent?
I don't know.
It's a good question.
He's so logical,
but other aspects of your life?
Yeah.
Let's see.
You know,
again,
can I zone out?
Sometimes I'm just fucking online being
a creep.
And how much of your time was spent
being a sex addict?
How much of your daily?
It's hard to say when I'm doing good,
I'm doing good.
When I'm doing bad,
there's been times where literally I get
home from Radio at 11 and then all of a
sudden it's like,
you know,
I've eaten and stuff,
but it's like,
man,
it's 8:30.
I gotta go to work.
Like the whole day was wasted.
It's like so many of those days.
It's like being in a fog.
Plus I don't sleep at all really.
I'm always tired because I fucking dumb
sleep apnea.
So you didn't,
you haven't done anything with your
sleep apnea?
I've done two tests.
I'm literally,
the only thing worse than a pedophile is
a fucking sleep apnea test technician.
Those fuckers,
uh,
I knew what I needed and I'll never
forgive the woman for not testing me for
it.
I need an asv machine which,
which handles complex apnea and um,
I'm finally going in for a test with the
new company probably within the next few
weeks,
but I need a mask that fits me properly.
Like,
you know,
I need a custom made mask and there was
a place that did him in Dallas,
but I can't find them anymore.
You lost weight?
Yeah.
Thank you.
I did.
Did that make an impact on your sleep?
It wasn't that,
it might've made,
it might've made the,
uh,
the,
obstructive apnea a bit different,
which is when your throat closed up
because of your tongue blocking it.
But,
uh,
the central apnea,
I don't think it affected by weight at
all.
What's the difference when your brain
just doesn't say breathe,
like that's what's going on with you and
I both complex like obstructive is your.
I'll lay there on my back and my tongue
goes,
yeah,
let's make that horrible sound.
But then there's times where I'm laying
on my side and I'll just go and I'll
wake up and I'll realize I haven't
breathed.
My Body didn't try to breathe.
So what happens is I wake up with an
intense itch somewhere like in my neck
or my stomach,
or I have to piss or I wake up like,
because your brain sends adrenaline to
your heart to wake you up because you're
not breathing.
Wow.
And what is the cause of that
oxygenation of the blood?
There's something off with that.
Um,
they don't know completely.
The central apnea is a newer one that
they're addressing obstructive,
they've done a lot with at a central
apnea they don't know as much about and
uh,
the masks are okay,
but it's hard to find a mass that you
totally comfortable with,
you know,
because,
uh,
the,
for the asv machines are very advanced
machine and it monitors your breathing
and when I'm not attempting to take a
breath,
it will do it for me and it will force
the Aaron,
whereas most cpap machines just are
patterned.
Shh,
shh.
They're kind of patterning your
breathing just to keep your throat open
so your tongue doesn't block it.
But the,
the,
the breathing.
So this asb machine has to do that and
it has to calculate when your brain
isn't trying to breathe.
It's really fucking weird,
frustrating situation because I'm an
insomniac anyway,
so I can't fall asleep with the mask.
Do you think any of this has to do with.
Is there any psychological things going
on?
I'm sure some of it,
the falling asleep part is like when I'm
acting out sexually,
I don't sleep as well.
Like if I'm sharing to you off the
videos right before it fucks my mind up
man,
like when I'm,
when I'm off sex shit for a week or so
and I'm not jacking off and I'm not
obsessing.
It's like my brain goes and I can
breathe and think normally and live
normally,
but when I am constantly fucking getting
that dopamine drip.
Like I literally was recently.
I kept jerking off before sleep,
but I wasn't coming.
I was just getting,
I would add too,
I get myself clothes and then stop and
then get myself clothes.
And I realized this the other night.
I feel high,
like I'm getting myself fucking high.
Like I'm like a chimp or a fucking a
journal going for a little fucking.
I'm just,
I'm going for this high feeling and then
I can sleep.
It's sickening.
How long have you had this issue?
My whole life.
It's been before I drank,
long before I did drugs.
There was this.
So,
um,
you know,
the sexual shit,
like the jerking off didn't start till I
was like 10 or 12 or whatever it was.
But uh,
the edging,
I don't come a lot of times because
that's the end of the high,
that's the end of the Ra.
So it's like I just keep it going and to
keep it going because then you don't
know where it's going to go and I don't
come for days or weeks on end because
I'm like,
well,
like we're,
we kinda just there.
Um,
because when I come I piss more because
in my fucking prostates all fucked up
because it's a disaster.
Your prostate fucks up because you don't
come.
Yeah.
When I,
when I,
when I went on,
I start and stop and start and stop and
start and stop it.
I finally come that the pis like an
animal,
um,
you know what I mean?
I think it just fucks you up a little
bit.
I don't know exactly what that is.
I don't have.
So this is,
but this is obviously something that you
don't like about yourself.
I hate it,
but I'm a huge joke or joke around about
it.
And you make a lot of comedy about it
because it's there.
It's always present.
But if you ever thought about doing
something to stop it.
Oh yeah.
Without a doubt,
man.
What would you do?
Um,
I would need to go to a certain 12 step
meetings which I've attempted to go to.
I've gone to talk to people in those
fellowships that get it and understand
and don't go,
oh,
you're just
a guy being a guy.
Like they get it man,
like,
you know,
um,
and I would have to just stop doing it.
Like it's really difficult because it's
like you act out.
Like if I drink,
I drank.
If I get high,
get high.
Of course I don't do those things.
But sexual shit of thought and it's like
eat food is really hard because you have
to eat to live.
But with sexual shit,
you know,
it's,
if I'm,
if I start thinking at that trigger
stuff and it's really,
really difficult to not fall into that
pattern.
I could offer you something.
Um,
I could offer you,
I don't know if you could do it,
but what you should think about doing is
an Iowaska session.
What does that.
WASCO is a,
is a shamanic session in Peru.
Usually they do it improve Brazil.
You could do it in America,
but it's not legal where you're.
You're doing this a common atory
psychedelic drug that allows you to look
at your life.
I couldn't look at all the issues that
you have that's wrong.
That's not a drug like that.
It's not a drug like it gets you high
and fucked up.
It doesn't get you fucked up.
It,
it shows you what's going on with your
life.
It'll show you all the.
It's the recidivism rate,
like the rate of fixing recidivism and
things like a heroin addiction and it's
one of the best cures ever.
That one is another one.
And other psychedelic drug called
Ibogaine.
I began,
if you know anything about hunter s
Thompson,
that's what he accused Ed Muskie of
being on during the,
uh,
it was in 1970 political campaigns.
He was a presidential campaigns.
He was a,
he wrote some stories in the rolling
stone saying that there was rumors that
Ed Muskie had brought into Brazilian
doctor and he was high on Ibogaine.
That.
But I began is actually a different kind
of drug than what he was describing.
It's actually a self reflective drug,
massively effective at curing people
addictions.
I have a friend who had a,
an oxycontin addiction and uh,
he was really fucked up.
He had hurt his back,
started getting on Oxycontin's,
then developed a real problem.
It's incredibly physically addictive.
And he did Ibogaine once,
cured him of,
he's never touched it since.
And now he runs a,
an Ibogaine center and helps people with
it.
This is the problem with me to a lot of
it comes down to lack of willingness or
a lack of willingness to act like I
intellectually I know what I have to do,
but you have a pattern in your mind that
needs to be reset and you could reset
your mind slowly over time or you can
reset it in one big fucking dump of
information like a dmt trip or like an
Ibogaine trip.
And I know you have this,
you have this thing about not wanting to
get high or not wanting to be
intoxicated,
but I think you're thinking of a
completely different effect than what
you're going to get on this,
on this experience.
You might be right.
I just,
it scares me too much.
Like it's something you should be scared
of what you're doing though too.
Obviously you don't like it and you
can't fix it.
Yeah,
absolutely.
I mean I,
but I can fix it.
It's a lack of.
Will it like.
It is a really weird thing that I,
I know what the answer is and like I
just like it too much.
I like it too much and they said to
think of liking.
Lust is weird,
but I like it.
Okay.
But let me ask you this then.
What don't you like about it?
I don't
like the fact that it distracts me.
It's consuming.
I'm much more creative.
Without it I am,
I'm,
I'm much more connected without it.
When I'm on it,
I see I'm,
I'm always behind glass and I feel like
I'm not seeing any real human
interaction at all,
so it just overwhelmed Sukato completely
overwhelming and I make enough money
where I can,
if I want to know.
Yeah,
I can't be stupid,
but I mean if I want to get a horse I
can get a horse,
you know,
and I do.
Do you think there's a way that you
could ever just sort of manage it?
Is it,
is it a way where you can still indulge
and enjoy a little bit of sex but not
let it overwhelm you?
Sure.
I don't think there's anything wrong
with being kinky or having a
relationship with dirty.
Like I'm not looking to be,
you know,
in and out through a sheet,
you know?
I just don't want to be.
There's a difference between that.
I don't want to be obsessed.
I don't want to be obsessed with it and
making it my whole point of existence.
That's just too much.
It don't get me wrong.
I'm sure you probably can cure it
without a psychedelic assurance,
but in the way you're talking about it,
it sounds like a lot of other
psychedelic,
a lot of other.
I'm obsessive compulsive sort of things
that psychedelics can cure.
Maybe you don't.
Maybe don't go to my free cams.
Have you been there yet?
No.
I go to [inaudible] dot com.
Who Doesn't love some good consulting
porn?
How challenging it is.
Coc holding everything that I wouldn't
really want that though.
I like.
I'll tell you what I love cold.
You wouldn't like that black guy to fuck
your woman in front of.
Never.
Never tell you what I like about the
movies.
It's not necessarily the black guy
fucking the woman.
It's the husband being there and filming
it.
Like there's something that the dynamics
of that is so like if it's just a black
guy,
fucking a woman,
like I don't really watch interracial
porn so I can't relate to the coc in it.
When it's a husband watching,
it's all about the woman.
She's being so dirty and so
inappropriate.
It makes me feel something and I think
that's a problem is I'm so numb that
like if I didn't do this shit for a
while then I get my dick sucked.
It feels good,
but when you,
when I'm fucking just won't leave my
dick alone.
Fucking I'm fucking wheatland my nipples
and trying to get a fucking disaster.
It's a disaster.
You can get numb,
totally numb.
So when I lay off for awhile then it
feels good again.
Then I don't need to go there.
But yeah,
I do manage it to a certain degree.
Like I'm more responsible than I should
be considering how fucking far gone I
am.
I'm much more careful than you think
that comes with being sober.
Like there are consequences I'm aware
of.
So I'm.
You've been sober since you were like
19,
18 years old.
Twenty six.
That's crazy.
Yeah.
That's a,
that's an amazing [inaudible] you gave
up on it real quick.
This is not for me.
You know?
Yeah.
If you rob see robbed three banks and
every time
one of your friends get shot and you go
to jail,
he liked robin.
Banks is just not for me.
That's what it was with this.
You can't do it.
Every time I do it there's a problem and
it's only gonna get worse and worse.
Well,
I think that along the same lines of
your obsessive thing with sex,
you can get that obsessive with
anything,
you know,
and it could be good.
Like you get that obsessed about
standup.
Yeah.
You know,
I mean I think especially if you go back
to your early days like you.
Do you remember like what it was like
when you first get an onstage that was
like really was like a drug you were
seeking.
It was a high.
The thing is though,
it doesn't turn me into somebody I don't
like.
Whereas when I drink,
I'm an ugly,
angry drunk.
I'm a violent drunk.
I'm a self destructive.
Physically drunk.
Do you think you still would be?
I know it.
I know there's not a doubt in my mind
and I'm not giving the sobriety company
line.
I just know how I think you know,
you and literally after I shot please be
offended,
which was over a year ago in Cleveland.
I wasn't happy with it and I'm like,
I just,
I'm like,
I just wanted to hang myself in the
closet and I was like,
fuck.
I put a belt up and I wasn't going to
do.
I knew I wasn't gonna do it.
You put a belt on.
Yeah.
But I knew I wouldn't do it.
This is not some psychotic cry for help.
I knew it wasn't gonna happen,
but I was so mad at myself.
I'm like,
you fucking stink.
That I all I could think about was just
that feeling of my fucking throat being
cut off.
But I,
I,
I wound up editing the special with
people and then liking it once it came
out a little bit and then I saw it
recently and I'm like,
it was good.
Like what?
What's wrong with you?
You Fuck?
Like,
I liked it a lot more.
This one I actually am very,
very happy with immediately,
but the other one,
it took a while and I think I had just
been doing the material a little longer
than I should have and by that I was
done with it.
That does happen.
How long had you been doing that
material?
For?
How many years?
Not Too.
Too Long.
A couple of year.
I mean,
you know.
Yeah,
maybe,
but this one I shot 10 months later.
I was ready to get this one.
I still,
I missed the material now.
Like I loved doing it so.
But I know how crazy.
I think in irrational and moment.
It's why I don't own a pistol.
It's why I don't know because I know I
would have that one moment that you can
take back.
Yeah.
I have a real similar problems.
I don't think it's as extreme as you
don't have a problem with drinking or
with drugs,
but I do have a lot of extremity,
a lot of,
uh,
I have a lot of impulses and a lot of
craziness,
but I keep it under wraps.
Right.
That's one of the reasons why I have to
work out.
I work out on a regular basis,
like I need discipline in my life in
order to keep order.
Right.
But if I got like that,
whether it was jerking off or if I got
into a drug or became like super
impulsive like that,
I'd like to think that I'd be able to
pull myself back because my objective,
because I looked at myself and I'm
self-analyze lot but,
but I'm not that confident and it's one
of the reasons why I've never touched
anything really addictive.
Yeah.
Besides alcohol,
which isn't addictive to me,
but I've never fucked with anything that
could get you.
Like Anthony's a fun drunk.
Anthony Columbia is a fun drunk.
I am not a
fun drunk.
I'm not.
I'm sorry.
I just have so much different than you
were when you were 18 to.
All right.
That's very true.
But because so many of these other
feelings are still there,
like I'm the drunk that all of a sudden
after four beers,
my nose is down,
but my eyes are up and I looked like a
fucking,
like,
give us remembering the shiny.
When Nicholson's wearing the maroon
coat,
that psych,
that's the look I have.
And um,
I,
I just don't trust it.
And the,
and the price to pay is just too much
and it's not worth it.
And nobody knows
better than you.
My friend tastes the same way.
He says,
I can't,
we can't do anything,
can't smoke a joint,
can't do it.
He goes,
it might be great,
but then I might wake up three days
later not knowing how the fuck I got
there.
And I don't miss it.
I,
I don't,
but I don't knock it either.
Like,
like you smoke pot and you have to run
this career.
You're driven.
You're a,
I think the best announcer in sports.
You have an amazing,
like a,
literally your life is very,
very professional and functional and
healthy.
You have a wife and kid,
like you do all these things and smoke
pot and like for you,
it's cool if I could do that gladly,
but I can't.
I just,
I know I can't,
not for any,
you know,
whatever.
We're just wired differently,
wired differently and people need to
really recognize that.
Uh,
I think it's,
it's a,
it's a really important point for me.
It helps me,
keeps me calm,
makes me nicer.
It makes me more relaxed so I wouldn't,
I wouldn't be productive stones.
Like,
you're productive.
Do you smoke a joint and come in and
talk for three hours?
If I didn't,
if I smoke,
if I took two hits to that,
I'll just look at the microphone.
Fucking dunce.
I would do nothing.
Yeah,
because you don't,
but you don't need it for whatever it
is.
It's for me.
It gives me a perspective that's not
available without the pot.
I can,
I can get.
I mean obviously I can get
introspective.
I can think about things deeply without
any help.
I don't need any marijuana or drugs,
but,
but when I take them,
I often feel like there's windows that
are open that wouldn't be open
ordinarily.
I mean,
Carl Sagan had a quote about that.
Let me see if I can remember it because
it's a fascinating quote because Carl
Sagan is one of my favorite.
Oh,
is great.
Science Katz,
who's a bad motherfucker.
This is what he said.
I am convinced that there are genuine
and valid levels of perception available
with cannabis and probably other drugs
which are through the defects of our
society and our educational system
unavailable to us without such drugs.
It's an interesting quote.
Yeah,
but that's just me.
It's probably correct.
For me.
Marijuana lets me know what I actually
want.
Like it sounds ridiculous,
but when I get high,
if I.
If I enjoy something when I'm high,
then I really enjoy it.
But if I get high and I'm like,
get me away from this fucking thing,
usually that's my actual feelings about
it.
Whether it's with people or whether it
enhances what,
how I already feel about certain people
enhances already feel about food or
about sex or.
But that's just me,
you know,
that's.
I took me till I was 30 before I
realized that even worked for me right
before that.
I thought it was all for idiots.
Yeah,
man,
I,
and again,
I wish I could do it,
but I,
I'm okay with the fact that I can't,
like,
I would like to manage the sec shit
better because I'm a better person when
I'm not doing it.
I'm a more connected person,
like I care about people,
but I can become very uncaring and very
distracted and very distant when I'm in
that mode because it's addiction.
It's like any other addiction.
You're not present.
And I think that it makes me not
present.
That's the,
that's the big point.
And that's what people don't have.
An addiction will never understand.
I've had many addictions.
Uh,
I've had a lot of video game problems,
behavioral type shit that really is just
like a drug addiction.
It becomes an addiction of video game
addiction.
Might as well be a drug addiction and
it's really similar to a sexual
addiction.
It focuses you on something outside.
It gets to zone out.
Sometimes it's just zone out.
It's just the feeling numb,
the numbness and it's like,
I like to think and I like to create and
I like to fucking sit at my computer and
write.
This is how it a fucking pervert.
Like when I wrote my books,
the second book especially I wrote at
the comedy cellar.
I would come up with stuff and I would
write it in the cellar because it was.
I was surrounded by people so I couldn't
jerk off.
Like I had to be in a public place to
sit on my laptop and right,
like,
you know what I mean?
I would just be in the corner writing
because I couldn't.
I could do enough instant messaging like
talk dirty so I could get a little
dopamine drip,
but I couldn't go the extra route,
which was the fucking Yank out my Dick,
my Dick soft.
I'm just yanking it against my dumb
stomach,
zone out,
click,
zone out.
Nothing real.
Nothing to feeling good.
How many times a day would you say?
I wouldn't even come all day.
Have you ever thought about taking a
laptop and disabling the Wifi
connection?
You could do that,
you know,
you can,
but I needed it for research and I liked
him being gay with the fucking research
because bashing public figures,
so I had to.
Oh,
like I was shocked and yeah.
Yeah.
And sometimes you need that for
reference and I also liked the
distraction of it because it puts less
pressure on me.
Like even if it's on watching black
sabbath videos,
I'll go on youtube and watch Sabbath
live in fucking to Melbourne again
because I feel like watching Ozzie
saying God is dead for the front and
that will distract me from it.
And then creatively like,
oh,
okay.
It allows me to step away for a second
mentally because I'm just forcing myself
know,
write,
I can't write.
Have you ever thought about trying some
other form of discipline,
like yoga or something along those
lines?
Yeah,
I would say that yoga would keep you
from being a sex addict,
but the fucking head of beef crumbs is
getting sued like a motherfucker for
rape and sexual assault and driving a
Rolls Royce,
a bunch of shit.
This guy's fucking crazy gangster.
You ever seen pictures of them?
Yeah,
I've seen one photo of him be grown sex
scandal,
something like that.
He dresses like a pimp and almost
literally.
How do you fucking not become a sex side
when?
When the girl in front of you was
wearing cellophane pants and her fucking
Qantas jumping out at you?
It looks like Al Jolson's face.
How do you not get turned on by that?
That's not him.
Is that him?
Yeah.
That's not the image I was thinking of,
but that's a good one.
Just thinking about him slinging and
Indian Dick all
over that room.
Oh,
yoga is good.
I've tried.
Working out has helped a little bit like
it makes me feel better about myself.
I'm more comfortable and confident like
you know where I want to be,
but I'm much better than I was,
so it's like I feel like I see results.
I bet if you did yoga four or five days
a week,
you could fucking hold on.
I bet you could hold on.
I think I roommate take off all the
doors in your place.
Probably just be jerking off in front of
each other.
After a while they would just sit back
to back like a fucking Rom composter
juggling at the same laptop.
Do you think that like prisoners,
they not jerk off because there's other
prisoners around it.
Just fucking do it just.
Well,
you talked to guys that worked at
prisons and they'll say they peaking the
cells and dudes just jacking it,
like looking right at him after a while
they just give up.
You just get used to it.
Yeah.
That's the human mind is so strange as
far as like what really gets us in some,
gets us on a track and now it's so
difficult to get off that track and that
obsession.
Like they just constantly wanting to
find another video or another video or
another video.
So it's a weird
Dang man did this to me.
It's maybe five or six times a day,
but it's like those camp sites and
these,
uh,
amateur video sites like submit your
flicks.
It's just like gold.
It's like nonstop.
Yeah,
you're just not as self aware as he is.
You're not trying to fix yourself.
Realizing that he's a mess and you're
like,
I'm perfect.
I did the uh,
I usually try to do it right when I wake
up.
Yup.
And I did the,
uh,
where I didn't wash my hands good
enough.
And I was at starbucks and I had a
little bit of a lotion still on my hand
when I was paying
fluffy.
Oh fuck that.
Good boy.
Good for you.
Fuck that.
Fuck.
Watching the lotion on your hands.
Get to the Guidestar,
but he's not going to discuss that.
You're going to talk about the times you
slimed people,
but I can't get onto the morning.
I can't do.
I'm not sexual activity.
Busy clearing out my sinuses and my had
nothing.
I don't want to fuck in the morning.
I want to talk.
I smelled your load once.
Remember you picked it out of your belly
button.
Oh yeah.
From the night before.
And he knows you're welcome.
It's one thing if you smell your own,
which is pretty disgusting,
but when you smell other people's.
I know I'm a disgusting person when I,
when I jerk off and I don't even bother
cleaning up,
I just wipe it with my underwear and put
them right back in my underwear and then
I get up in the morning and take a leak
and I smell it usually on the road
maintenance jerking off and then I get
up in the morning on the road to Piss
and I lift up the toilet and pull my
dick out.
My what is,
that's just like,
like the.
Yeah,
like the banks of a polluted river.
It's so gross.
Wipe it right off live and right off
comes right off.
If you could,
if you could fix one aspect of yourself
though,
that's the thing that you would like to
get on track?
Absolutely.
Because I think it stops me career wise.
Like I have a good career where like I
enjoy where I'm at,
but it's,
it,
it allows me to stagnate on a level
where I should
not be stagnating and it permits me to
be comfortable where I shouldn't be
comfortable and it's like a little
safety signal,
little security blanket where it
shouldn't be about getting maybe like,
you know,
like a cock lock or one of those
chastity belt locks where he has a key
and you turn them on.
You had to find something about that.
I would just get Mr to put a strap on,
on and spit on me,
you know,
always.
There's always a way.
Do you still like that shit?
Like you're,
you're,
like,
you're in a dominatrix isn't sexy.
I mean,
I haven't,
I haven't in a while,
but uh,
they can be very sexy.
Sure.
If they're,
they're good.
If they know what they're doing,
if they're just like the whole dirtiness
of it.
Absolutely.
Man,
I love the perversion.
I love a woman who can read me.
Every guy wants to be owned,
whether you're dominant or submissive,
and when a woman can read me and
anticipate what I want,
I love that.
So fired up,
but it's hot man.
Just enjoy that though.
Why?
Why does it have to be an obsession?
Is Is there a balance that can be
achieved here?
Yeah,
you can just enjoy the sex and sexuality
and just not tweak on all day.
It's greed.
It's being greedy.
It's wanting one as they say more than
my share.
Twenty more than my share of pleasure
and more than my share of experiences.
It's walk into a candy store and not
picking a candy bar.
It's grabbing for everything and then
shoving it into my fucking face and the
crime that I have a stomach ache,
but you've got enough discipline to work
out and lose all this weight like you've
changed your body over the last six
months or a year or so.
How many?
How much weight have you lost?
I mean in the last year I'd say close to
30.
Your face,
your body,
everything looks totally different.
Yeah.
Well,
yeah.
It's.
It's a overall.
I was,
I think I'm like one 46,000,
47.
I was at one point,
I was tapping out a lot in the one
sixties,
hitting one seventies at one point a
couple years ago,
few years ago.
I was in the eighties,
I suppose to have pictures of myself.
I want a fucking oinker.
I was really disgusting,
but it's good to remember that stuff and
uh,
I feel much better to my eating's on
that.
Perfect.
You know,
but it's nice though to get that under
wraps,
right?
Acute.
You've handled that one aspect of your
physicality getting out of control.
But I have at least a pattern that's
healthy for it.
And I got a trainer sessions at least
three,
sometimes four days a week,
so yeah.
Yeah.
Well maybe you could figure out a way to
just get another pattern,
you know.
Isn't that something that your mother
told you replace something bad with?
Did you know Dr Phil said that.
It's funny.
My mother on my second cd left that
voicemail and she was right.
Jimmy.
I was like,
why don't you go to the gym,
get to meet a nice girl?
And she was right.
Bible.
I have a fucking fart brewing right now.
It's going to be.
I'm going to do it in the car with
Jonathan.
It's going to be fucking hang in there
like much bigger.
You are in this picture.
This was in Vegas when Opie and Anthony
was in Vegas.
So what year was this?
Like 2003.
I have a lot fatter than that.
Look up.
Uh,
I mean that was,
that was even,
that was fantastic.
I asked me a Deacon Jones.
I love that photo.
Yeah.
I was a fucking pig there,
but not.
That was in Vegas too,
right?
Yeah,
he was hanging out with some in Vegas.
I remember that.
That was a fun show that Vegas Vegas to
California as a California public.
Like the poker thing?
Yeah.
The poker thing.
That was when Anthony was playing,
right?
Yep.
Fun Times.
And Lp stepped on fasteners.
Cake.
Theoretically.
Some metaphoric.
Yeah.
And asked her to call them a destroyer.
Hilarious.
Yeah,
it was funny.
That was really fun.
The,
um,
that,
those shows that you guys used to do,
how come you guys stopped doing those,
those big comedy shows?
Um,
it just became,
well,
we lost terrestrial radio,
which I was happy for it,
but it became harder to do and it became
harder to get guys booked and now we
just,
it just went away.
The merger happened and things changed
once we merged,
there was disadvantages to it and
there's advantages to it.
Um,
you know,
I liked being in our old studio at Xm.
I liked the thing about Sirius I like is
the guests we can get are much better
because already in the building.
So a lot of times we get people that we
would not have gotten ever.
Um,
you know,
there's been some great.
We're open to a much larger group of
people now.
So,
you know,
the good with the bad.
Do you know what your numbers are?
No idea.
I probably could find out,
but I don't ask.
I just don't want to know because I
don't wanna be disappointed.
Um,
I just,
I don't know.
I know I have a decent amount of
followers and decent amount of fans.
Um,
I've,
I have no fucking idea what I mean as
far as like how many people listened to
know,
kill me every day.
I don't even know how we'd find that out
because they know arbitron diary.
I think they do,
but they don't want to tell us because
we sent out surveys tuned in you,
you have to be tuned into that frequency
or that it doesn't tell you that way.
Nah,
I think through a lot of times they
could do listeners surveys,
but uh,
which I guess work like arbitron
diaries,
but I don't know,
man.
So antiquated,
isn't it?
That's shitty.
Do I really think that if you weren't on
it,
you would have the biggest fucking
podcast in the world?
Oh No,
I don't think you'd have a huge podcast.
I feel like I've been,
I,
I'm,
I'm not fishing.
I really mean like,
I feel like I'm boring when I talked to
a lot.
I just,
can't I fuck it wouldn't be out of my
mind.
I like to snipe.
I like to fucking sit there and watch
fucking Greg and Tony do the heavy
lifting and I pipe in with,
like you said,
the fucking quick shot or I fucking,
I'm the,
I'm the fucking sniper and full metal
jacket.
I'll just shoot a few bullets and then
sit back and let them do the heavy
lifting and I liked that.
Well you guys have a great relationship
to.
You guys have been doing it together so
long,
but I think if the three of you build
together,
it would just,
you could still.
I think you could maintain the exact
same amount of income.
I think it'd be the exact same amount of
people listening if not more,
just.
I think that's the future being Anthony
podcast.
Yeah,
I was just about bringing that.
Yes,
we do the podcast.
So,
uh,
and how does that work?
They just go on,
it's on itunes and a lot of times it's
best of the week plus a couple of old
bits are a part.
Yeah,
there's an old bit in there.
It's basically just to get people
because they don't want to give away
content either.
It's just to get people who have heard
of the show to check it out and see if
they like it.
Um,
but a lot of times the fans already have
the content because they've heard it
already.
Well,
I'm going to tell you this man,
if it wasn't for you guys,
I don't think I would've ever started a
podcast.
And if it wasn't for Anthony Anthony
doing live from the compound,
Brian and I would've never started doing
that.
Ustream show this show that kind of
started it out.
And before that,
the uh,
was the Justin TV.
We did a few of those.
Yeah,
we did a few of those in the green
rooms.
Like we kind of had an idea of doing
something like this a long time ago.
But seeing anthony do it from his place
really motivated me because anthony set
up a green screen and put a professional
desk in there and had professional
microphones and cameras.
I mean he really went balls out.
He told me he spent like a stupid amount
of money to convert the downstairs of
his house until the recording studio.
And this is a guy already has a fucking
full time gig and if you never seen live
for the compound,
he did some with his ex girlfriend
Melissa,
where he would get fucking shit faced.
Hammered.
He would do karaoke while holding a
machine gun.
Yeah,
he.
He was hammered and he would take calls.
I called him once he was on,
I was watching.
I was like,
this is amazing.
And he was just hammered,
hammered,
drinking wine,
holding it up,
loving it.
Well the fun thing is the accomplished
all that.
And he built that studio.
All this while,
like you said,
doing a full time Gig and drinking like
William Holden and I'm fucking jerking
off and I can't get myself to fucking
motivated like that.
That's humiliating to me.
Like.
And I've watched anthony build that
studio and I'm like,
look at what he's doing.
I can't even rearrange my apartment.
I fucking just stagnate.
Start and don't finish.
Start and don't finish it.
I fucking hate it.
Yeah.
I had always had this idea to do
something like that when,
after seeing him do it,
he did his,
his thing was so interesting because at
the time when he was doing that,
nobody was doing something live on
ustream.
Like professionally.
He would like have different
backgrounds,
you know,
he could have a background that was like
the city because the green screen it
gets switched the background and turn
into whatever the fuck he wanted,
which was so bad ass.
It's a great idea.
And he know when he does it,
when he eventually just turns it on and
pots up the mix anytime he wants,
he just goes downstairs and hits the
switch and boom,
you know,
and then,
uh,
Brian set up the place of the ice house
and that's like the natural progression
of setting this place up.
I need a technical partnership with
somebody.
I need somebody in New York who can
technically box idea.
Yeah,
obviously.
But then Richard intellectually just
take it and make it so much better as
well as intellectual dominated.
What can't serious.
Don't they have sound guys?
I don't mean with that.
I mean,
with somebody's independence,
like if I want to do,
because I want it,
I told you I want to talk show.
Like I really,
I love interviewing people,
I love it.
And uh,
I want to do that.
Well that's what a podcast is.
Yeah.
But I'll be able to do it like on TV as
far as I want to do it on and let it
out.
I couldn't help it.
It was beginning to cause me great pain.
It was like a secret.
So I would like to do that.
So you want to do it on like fx or
something like that,
like come out.
They have him five nights a week now
they would have known what I mean like
that kind of fun.
I think it's a fun thing to do and uh,
I would like to do it.
Yeah,
that does seem like a fun thing to do
and you would have access to a lot of
really fascinating people by doing
something like that.
So yeah,
and again,
I like to talk to people and interview
them and you know,
it's not a,
it's fun to do.
It's really fun to.
I was talking to Ben Kingsley on time
and I'm like,
well how great is this?
He has to answer my questions.
If I bumped into him in a fucking Oscar
party,
he'd spit on me,
but here he is sitting next to me.
Oh yes,
yes.
Answering because he doesn't want to
look at it.
It's like that's the cool part about it.
Yeah,
and especially if they come in
specifically to sit down with you for x
amount of time,
you know,
you could really dig into somebody if
you're talking to them for an hour or
two hours or whatever it would be.
Yeah.
That's the,
I think,
you know,
it'd be great if you did like a Bob
Costas type thing.
There are Bob Costas had later with Bob
Costas.
Oh yeah.
And he just was just real simple.
Is that Kim at a desk with a person or
sit down with them for a full hour?
No,
I don't know.
That could hold the audience for an
hour.
I want to do sketches to that.
I appreciate like I have some things I
wanted to do.
So you want to essentially host the
tonight show type situation,
but nothing that quite that structured
or that,
you know what I mean?
It would be.
It would have to have a much different
feeling than that.
But would you want to do it like
showtime style uncensored?
Oh yeah.
So that's what you'd want to do?
Yeah.
Just say whatever I launched.
Yeah,
you got to do it on showtime or hbo
either.
We're a bunch of other cable channels
where there are a couple of language
issues,
but not many millions channels.
Now they're starting to open up and a
lot of people don't realize the FCC
doesn't control cable.
They only control broadcast television,
NBC,
CBS,
that,
that kind of shit.
When you get to cable,
they essentially self-impose
advertisers.
Yeah.
Some of them.
That's why like the shield was able to
say shit and asshole and everybody was
like,
what the hell didn't go fuck.
They don't go as far as fuck,
but they can.
Did you like the shield?
Spike did.
I never saw this shield.
I've heard it's great.
Loved it.
I'm a wire fanatic and then people tell
me you'll like this if you ever see the
wire.
I only watched a couple episodes of the
I need to get back to a.
people always tell me that it's the
greatest show ever.
It's my favorite show ever.
Fucking masterpiece.
I think game of thrones is my favorite
game of thrones to the wires better.
I thought so.
Yeah.
It was realistic about drug dealing and
uh,
I've,
I just,
I loved it and I love the characters
out.
Check it out,
Jimmy.
And you're special.
When does it come out?
August 23rd.
I thank you on epics and epics.
Hd Dot com.
You can get.
Just sign up for a trial if you want to
watch it online if your cable provider
doesn't hold record that I shot it in a,
it looks like the Tabernacle.
And uh oh,
that's in,
that's in a.
no,
it's in Somerville.
Mass.
Somerville.
Couple weekS before the bombing.
I wish it was after the bombing because
I would've addressed it,
which were really.
Of course I would have mocked the
bombers.
Yeah,
it was talking about those fuCking.
I was talking about kicking their mother
and the content.
Fuck them.
Yeah,
it was bashing them.
Yeah.
I would love to.
The mother and the current.
Yeah,
I,
yeah.
Her womb is a terra camp like.
Yeah,
I had a whole bunch of fun with that
fucking brothers.
So it's on epix.
When's the date again?
August 23rd and it requires a lot and if
you get the trial online you can watch
it whenever you want.
A beautiful and I'm happy with it.
So that's epix.com
picks hd.com.
Epics hd.com.
And jim norton on twitter.
Jim norton,
so following me,
dirty fox and jim norton dotcom is
finally going up.
It's been too long on this motherfucker,
man.
You really fun guy.
I really enjoy talking to you and like I
said,
I really appreciate your,
your,
your intelligent take on that debate
about jokes and rape jokes with lindy
west.
I thought that was,
it was really important and I think it
was really important that you did it.
Thank you.
And I actually liked her too.
I'm not saying that the light.
I genuinely liked her and we talked
after on the following and she's
actually really nice.
She's not some psychotic,
you know?
I think that a lot of our takes on these
things.
A lot of the interaction that we have,
whether it's a blog to blog or twitter
to twitter,
it's,
it's such a limited way of communicating
and a lot of these same people that we
have disagreements with online.
If we sat down with them in a rational
sort of normal setting like this and
just talked,
we'd probably see each other's point a
lot better and have like some healthy
discussions about these things as
opposed to these like these snipe
attacks that people like to do in blogs
and twitter and go back and forth with
each other.
It's,
there's a lot missing in those one way
interactions.
When I say something and then you say
something and you know when you
communicate with each other,
a lot of times you can.
You can get to know someone a lot
better.
That's why I liked that conversation was
you could tell there was some real
discourse going on there,
which regardless of which side you take.
All right,
that's it fuckers.
Thank you.
Thank you and thanks to squarespace.com.
Go to squarespace.com
and use the code word joe and the number
eight altogether.
One word joe eight and save yourself
some cash song on a a beautiful self
constructed website and remember it's
super easy to do,
so easy that they'll let you try doIng
it first before you even use your credit
card information.
Thanks also to audible.com.
If you go to audible.com
forward slash joe,
you will get one free audio book and 33
days of the bull serve asshole shouts.
We're also brought to you by on it.com.
That's o n n I t use the code name rogan
and save 10 percent off any and all
supplements I'm trying to do.
Um,
uncle creepy this week.
That's ian mccall.
I'm gonna.
See if I can get him in here before I
take off from boston and got some other
people in town to maybe brian and wants
to do one as well.
So the date real quick,
I'm going to be with tony hinchcliffe in
standup live,
september 26.
And you guys [inaudible] dot com.
That's in phoenix,
Arizona.
You freaks.
Alright,
we love you guys.
We'll see you soon.